Hello and welcome to our second drink of season three, episode seven, branch closing. This is a great breakdown. We got to talk with Charles Esten, who played Josh, you know, the manager of the Stanford branch. Yes. And he's just such a great guy. He really is. Well, I thought I'd kick off our second drink with a letter from Yusuf A, who said, is Josh
你好，欢迎收听我们第三季第七集《分部关闭》的第二杯饮品。这一集分析得非常棒。我们采访了饰演斯坦福分部经理乔什的查尔斯·埃斯滕。是的，他真是个很棒的人。确实如此。我想用优素福·A的一封来信开启我们的第二杯饮品，他问乔什
wearing the same suit Michael wore in his birthday episode? Is he? Did you go check? Well, you know I love a side by side photo. I don't know anyone that loves them more. I went to both episodes. I grabbed photos. Let me see.
穿的是不是迈克尔在生日那集穿的同一套西装？是吗？你去核实了吗？你知道我喜欢对比照片。我不认识比我更喜欢对比照片的人了。我看了这两集，截了图。让我看看。
And I'll tell you what, I see why Yusuf is asking this question. They are both wearing dark blue pinstriped suits with like white pinstripes. They are both wearing like bright blue shirts and they're both wearing a tie that has like white, blue and kind of black in it. So very sort of similar looks.
我跟你说，我明白优素福为什么会问这个问题了。他们穿的都是深蓝色细条纹西装，配着白色条纹。他们都穿着亮蓝色的衬衫，领带里都有白色、蓝色和黑色。所以看起来非常相似。
Very similar, but here's my side by side and they are not the same. They are not identical, but wow. The shirt looks the same. The shirt does. It's the tie that looks different, right? And the suit as well, I think is slightly different. The cut, yeah. And the pinstripes in Michael's suit are more prominent,
非常相似，但这是我的对比图，它们并不一样。它们不是完全相同的，但哇，衬衫看起来确实一样。衬衫确实一样。领带看起来不同，对吧？而且我觉得西装也略有不同。剪裁，是的。迈克尔西装上的细条纹更显眼，
whereas Josh's suit, they're a little more subtle. But that's the same shirt. It's the same idea. And you know how Michael always admires people he thinks are cool? Do you think there's a chance he saw Josh in Stanford wearing this ensemble and he went out and bought something similar and then wore it on his birthday? For sure.
而乔什的西装条纹则更细微。但衬衫是一样的。思路是一样的。你知道迈克尔总是崇拜他认为很酷的人吗？你觉得有没有可能他看到乔什在斯坦福穿这套衣服，然后就出去买了一套类似的，并在生日那天穿上了？肯定是的。
I think so too. Well, a fun part of this episode are all of the reactions from people when they find out that the branch is closing. There's a series of talking heads, and the writers must have really liked writing these because there were a ton of candy bag alts for them. Yes! I found mine for Pam! Same!
我也这么认为。这一集里有趣的部分是大家得知分部要关闭时的各种反应。有一系列采访镜头，编剧们一定很喜欢写这些，因为有很多备选台词。是的！我找到了帕姆的备选台词！我也是！
I found mine for Angela! Okay, so the Angela one that made it into the episode was the one in the original script. This is Angela's reaction to the branch closing. Let's hear it. I don't want to blame anyone in particular. I think everyone's to blame. It's very on-brand for Angela. Yes.
我找到了安吉拉的！好吧，最终出现在剧集里的安吉拉的那段是原剧本里的。这是安吉拉对分部关闭的反应。我们来听听。我不想责怪任何人。我觉得每个人都有责任。这非常符合安吉拉的风格。是的。
To point fingers at everyone. So here was the candy bag alt for that talking head. Some of these people are in for a rough time. Not me. The world always needs accountants. But the stage direction says she doesn't look so sure of that. Mm-hmm.
把矛头指向每个人。所以这是那个采访镜头的备选台词。这些人中的一些人要倒霉了。我不会。世界总是需要会计的。但舞台指导说她看起来并不那么确定。嗯。
Okay, so here is the Pam talking head that made it into the episode. It's a blessing in disguise. Actually, not even in disguise. In my fantasy, I always thought I would slap someone, make a big speech, and storm out forever. But this is good, too. Hmm. In my fantasy, I always thought I would slap someone, make a big speech, and storm out forever. But this is good too.
好了，这是出现在剧集里的帕姆的采访镜头。这是因祸得福。其实，甚至算不上因祸得福。在我的幻想中，我一直以为我会扇某人一巴掌，发表一番长篇大论，然后永远地愤然离去。但这也不错。嗯。在我的幻想中，我一直以为我会扇某人一巴掌，发表一番长篇大论，然后永远地愤然离去。但这也不错。
All right. So that was actually my candy bag alt. My candy bag alt made it into the episode. The original talking head that was in the shooting draft actually said this, it's a blessing in disguise. Or actually, it's not even in disguise. Sometimes when I'm home, I answer my phone, Dunder Mifflin, this is Pam.
好了。所以那其实是我的备选台词。我的备选台词被用进了剧集里。拍摄剧本里的原始采访镜头其实是这样说的：这是因祸得福。或者其实，甚至算不上因祸得福。有时我在家接电话时，会说“邓德·米夫林，我是帕姆”。
So I'm hoping that'll stop now. I like that. Me too. So finally, we got this letter from Harshita V. That said, not a question, but something I thought you might like. Over the course of the entire nine seasons, Stanley and Creed only talk to each other once, and they only say four words to each other,
所以我希望这种情况现在能停止了。我喜欢这个。我也是。最后，我们收到了哈希塔·V的这封信。她说，不是一个问题，但我想你们可能会感兴趣。在整整九季的过程中，斯坦利和克里德只交谈过一次，而且他们只对彼此说了四个字，
and that happens during this episode, Branch Closing. Lady, did you know that was a thing? I Googled it, I looked everywhere. There are threads on Reddit that are all about how Stanley and Creed never speak to one another. I did not realize that, but now I'm trying to play scenes in my head. And even though sometimes they're sort of in proximity to one another, they're not really interacting. You're right. Yeah. So there is a scene in Fun Run where they're interacting. They have gone off the
而这发生在这一集《分部关闭》中。女士，你知道这件事吗？我谷歌了一下，到处都查了。Reddit上有关于斯坦利和克里德从不交谈的帖子。我之前没意识到，但现在我试着在脑海中回放场景。即使有时他们离得很近，他们也没有真正的互动。你说得对。是的。在《趣味跑》里有一个他们互动的场景。他们和奥斯卡一起偏离了
course with Oscar and they're having lunch together, Oscar, Creed and Stanley. Yeah. They don't have any lines to one another. So they're all seated at the table, but they don't share any dialogue. So I thought that in honor of their only time saying words to one another, maybe we should hear it. Yeah. It's from this episode, Stanley has a talking head where he says he's excited about the branch closing and how he's gonna take an early retirement package.
路线，他们在一起吃午饭，奥斯卡、克里德和斯坦利。是的。他们之间没有任何台词。所以他们都坐在桌子旁，但没有对话。所以我认为为了纪念他们唯一一次对彼此说话，也许我们应该听听。是的。来自这一集，斯坦利有一个采访镜头，他说他对分部关闭感到兴奋，以及他将如何获得提前退休金。
Creed is walking around the bullpen taking photos of people and here's what they say to one another. Feeling nostalgic? Yeah, nostalgic. That's it. Wow. Four words. We have to ask them about that.
克里德在办公区走来走去给人们拍照，这就是他们对彼此说的话。怀旧吗？是的，怀旧。就是这样。哇。四个字。我们得问问他们这件事。
I feel like we need to. It's really funny. I was trying to think if there were other characters that just never really seemed to interact or have dialogue together. And for a very long time, it was Pam and Meredith. Well, also Jim and Angela. They hardly ever speak to each other. Yeah. Very rarely. I would get paired with Kate for background work. Mm-hmm.
我觉得我们需要问问。这真的很有趣。我试着想还有没有其他角色似乎从不互动或没有对话。很长一段时间里，是帕姆和梅雷迪思。嗯，还有吉姆和安吉拉。他们几乎从不说话。是的。非常罕见。我经常和凯特被安排在一起做背景工作。嗯。
So you would see our characters together, but we never really talked. Right. So interesting. Well, I love it when people write in with these observations. I know. The show keeps on giving, lady.
所以你会看到我们的角色在一起，但我们从不真正交谈。对。真有趣。好吧，我喜欢人们写信分享这些观察。我知道。这部剧不断给人惊喜，女士。
It's pretty cool. All right, everyone. Please enjoy our breakdown of Branch Closing. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
这太酷了。好了，各位。请欣赏我们对《分部关闭》的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hi folks. Hello everybody.
现在我们正在为你制作《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们都会解析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。各位好。
I'm sorry, I feel like I just shouted. I won't do that again. If you shouted, then what did I do? I don't know, I don't know. I'll pull back. We're a little amped up today, guys. We're excited about this episode. We're am, guys. We're excited about this episode. We're amped up. We're excited about this episode. Also, seeing my BFF's face and Sam and Cody,
抱歉，我觉得我刚才喊出来了。我不会再那样了。如果你喊了，那我做了什么？我不知道，我不知道。我会收敛一点。我们今天有点兴奋，伙计们。我们对这一集很兴奋。我们很兴奋，伙计们。我们对这一集很兴奋。我们很激动。我们对这一集很兴奋。还有，看到我最好的朋友的脸，还有萨姆和科迪，
like the four of us, is kind of just like one of the highlights of my week. Every week it's one of the highlights of my week. Yeah, it's true. Let's talk about The Office. This week's episode is branch closing. It is season three, episode seven, written by Mike Shor and directed by Tucker Gates. Yes, Tucker Gates directed four episodes, one of which people like absolutely flip out over is the threat level midnight.
我们四个人在一起，简直是我这周的亮点之一。每周这都是我这周的亮点之一。是的，是真的。我们来聊聊《办公室》。本周的剧集是《分部关闭》。这是第三季第七集，由迈克·舒尔编剧，塔克·盖茨执导。是的，塔克·盖茨执导了四集，其中一集人们绝对为之疯狂，那就是《午夜威胁》。
We'll get there. Yes, oh yes. All right, here's a summary for this episode, jumping right in. Jan tells Michael that the Dunder Mifflin Scranton branch is shutting down. What? Michael, of course, shares this news with the rest of the office,
我们会讲到那一集的。是的，哦，是的。好了，这是这一集的摘要，直接进入正题。简告诉迈克尔，邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿分部要关闭了。什么？迈克尔当然把这个消息告诉了办公室里的其他人，
even though Jan told him not to. I mean, what, are you gonna tell Michael something and expect him not to just blurt it out? He's, like, emotion-driven. The guy cannot hold anything in. No, he can hold nothing, basically. Yeah. So everyone is wondering what their new life will be like. They're talking about it.
尽管简告诉他不要说。我的意思是，什么，你要告诉迈克尔一件事，还指望他不会脱口而出？他是个情绪化的人。这家伙什么都藏不住。不，他基本上什么都藏不住。是的。所以每个人都在想他们的新生活会是什么样。他们在讨论这件事。
They're thinking about it. Meanwhile, Michael and Dwight drive to David Wallace's house in hopes of ambushing him and saving the branch. They're going to save us, guys. Even if they have to be aggressive. Like, what? They're going to show up at this guy's house? What are they thinking? Thank God he didn't come home. Well, we eventually learned that Josh from Stanford leveraged his position to get a new job at Staples, and the Stanford branch will now be closing. The Scranton branch will absorb some of their employees,
他们在思考这件事。与此同时，迈克尔和德怀特开车去大卫·华莱士家，希望能伏击他并挽救分部。他们要救我们，伙计们。即使他们必须表现得咄咄逼人。就像，什么？他们要出现在这个人的家里？他们在想什么？谢天谢地他没回家。好吧，我们最终得知斯坦福的乔什利用他的职位在史泰博找到了一份新工作，斯坦福分部现在要关闭了。斯克兰顿分部将吸收他们的一些员工，
which means, guys, Jim is coming back. Oh, Jim is coming back. It's a big episode. That's a lot of information we find out in this episode. So much information, and it sets up the rest of the season really. It really does. Yeah we're gonna and this is we're gonna get our new characters now. Ed Helms, Rashida Jones, Angela we're finally next week gonna be able to
这意味着，伙计们，吉姆要回来了。哦，吉姆要回来了。这是重要的一集。我们在这一集里发现了很多信息。太多的信息了，它实际上为剩下的赛季奠定了基础。确实如此。是的，我们要，这是我们要迎来新角色了。埃德·赫尔姆斯，拉什达·琼斯，安吉拉，我们下周终于可以
interact with those Stanford people. Yeah and they really they really get under people's skin it's so fun. All right but we're getting ahead. We're getting ahead of ourselves. Jenna now you and I were being chatty on the phone yesterday. Jenna, you were a little, I don't know, braggy to me on the phone yesterday. You said you had fantastic fast facts you wouldn't tell me. So what do you got? What do you got? You were a little braggy. I was a little braggy because I am actually really proud of these fast facts. The first one is a little soft. I'm going to just preface it now that we've built it up. But fast fact number one is that this episode of Branch Closing, it now streams as a supersized
和那些斯坦福的人互动了。是的，他们真的，他们真的让人很烦，这太有趣了。好了，但我们说得太远了。我们说得太远了。珍娜，昨天你和我在电话里聊得很开心。珍娜，昨天你在电话里有点，我不知道，有点炫耀。你说你有很棒的速记事实，但你不告诉我。所以你有什么？你有什么？你有点炫耀。我有点炫耀，因为我其实真的很为这些速记事实感到自豪。第一个有点软。既然我们已经铺垫了，我就先说明一下。但速记事实一号是，这一集《分部关闭》，现在作为超长版
episode. It's longer than a regular episode. It runs about 30 minutes. But when it first aired, it was a regular episode. This ran on NBC as a shorter episode, but immediately following the airing on television, NBC released what they called a producer's cut, where they put back some deleted scenes. And that is the version that now streams today,
剧集播放。它比普通剧集长。大约有30分钟。但它最初播出时，是一集普通的剧集。这在NBC上作为较短的剧集播出，但在电视播出后立即，NBC发布了他们所谓的制片人剪辑版，他们放回了一些删除的场景。这就是今天播放的版本，
this producer's cut. Lady, that's a very solid first fast fact. Oh, well, thank you so much. Yeah, that's really good. first fast fact. Oh, well, thank you so much. Yeah, that's really good. Thank you so much. I forgot that. I forgot that. And when I watched it, I noticed it was longer.
这个制片人剪辑版。女士，这是一个非常扎实的第一个速记事实。哦，好吧，非常感谢。是的，这确实是很好的第一个速记事实。哦，好吧，非常感谢。是的，这确实很好。非常感谢。我忘了那个。我忘了那个。当我观看它时，我注意到它更长了。
And I was like, we always had the big announcement about our super-sized episodes. Remember? It was always usually at the end of the season. And I was like, how did this one get in there? That's how. OK. First of all, I think that this really speaks to how much stuff we used to cut from episodes. Because when you watch this episode, it feels awesome.
我就想，我们总是对我们的超长剧集有大公告。记得吗？通常总是在赛季末。我就想，这一集是怎么混进去的？就是这样。好的。首先，我认为这真的说明了我们过去从剧集中剪掉了多少东西。因为当你观看这一集时，感觉太棒了。
You're like, oh, yes. And it kind of shows all the things that we used to have to cut out. And as we go along, I'll point out some of the things that only got to stay in because of this added time. I'll mention the things that were cut for the network airing. Okay. But I think this also speaks to a time historically when websites and the idea of web traffic or exclusive web content, it was just blowing up. This is the very first kind of exclusive web
你会想，哦，是的。它展示了我们过去不得不剪掉的所有东西。随着我们的进行，我会指出一些因为这段额外时间才得以保留的东西。我会提到那些为电视网播出而剪掉的东西。好的。但我认为这也说明了一个历史时期，当时网站和网络流量或独家网络内容的概念，它刚刚爆发。这是《办公室》的第一种独家网络
content of the office that NBC put out, this producer's cut, and it was because NBC wanted to drive traffic to their website. Yes, which is also why we did those webisodes. We started doing more and more content for NBC.com. I started doing a thing called Adventures with Angela, where I would go around the set and make these videos and they put it on NBC.com because they were really starting to see, hey, this internet thing is probably going to be the way to go. And this was still before social media.
内容，NBC发布的，这个制片人剪辑版，这是因为NBC想为他们的网站增加流量。是的，这也是为什么我们制作那些网络剧的原因。我开始做一件叫《与安吉拉的冒险》的事情，我会去片场制作这些视频，他们把它们放在NBC.com上，因为他们真的开始看到，嘿，这个互联网的东西很可能是未来的方向。而这还是在社交媒体之前。
This was still before Instagram. Twitter was around, but it was very much just starting. And it wasn't what it is today. But yeah, now you almost expect it. I feel like now you watch a television program and you're like, where's my extra content? Where's my behind the scenes? Where's my extended cuts? But this was like just the very beginning, and branch closing was part of that. I find that fascinating, Jenna. And also, yeah, you're right. This is a time stamp,
这还是在Instagram之前。推特当时已经存在，但它确实只是刚刚开始。它不是今天这个样子。但是的，现在你几乎期待它了。我觉得现在你观看一个电视节目，你会想，我的额外内容在哪里？我的幕后花絮在哪里？我的加长剪辑在哪里？但这就像刚刚开始，而《分部关闭》就是其中的一部分。我觉得这很迷人，珍娜。而且，是的，你说得对。这是一个时间戳，
right? If we're tracking old tech, our show started before there was streaming. Oh, Angela, FastFact number two is a major old tech tracking. You're going to love this. What? All right. On January 9, 2007, Apple introduced the first iPhone. I don't know if you remember this, but it was unveiled during a presentation by Steve Jobs. We got some mail from Aaron McDonald with what might be my favorite tip-off ever. He said that the cold open from this episode was the first ever piece of video played on the iPhone, and it was done during that presentation
对吧？如果我们追踪旧技术，我们的节目开始于流媒体出现之前。哦，安吉拉，速记事实二号是一个重大的旧技术追踪。你会喜欢这个的。什么？好的。2007年1月9日，苹果推出了第一款iPhone。我不知道你是否记得这个，但它是在史蒂夫·乔布斯的演讲中揭幕的。我们收到了亚伦·麦克唐纳的一封邮件，里面可能有我最喜欢的爆料。他说这一集的冷开场是iPhone上播放的第一段视频，而且是在那次演讲中完成的
by Steve Jobs. Wow. We were part of this global moment, like, without even knowing it. It blew my mind. Here is something even more crazy. I watched the whole presentation. Also during the presentation, Steve Jobs,
由史蒂夫·乔布斯完成。哇。我们是这个全球时刻的一部分，甚至都不知道。这让我大吃一惊。这里还有更疯狂的事情。我看了整个演讲。在演讲过程中，史蒂夫·乔布斯，
when he's showing you how the music stuff works, he plays the Green Day song, Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Angela, in season six of The Office, Dwight and Andy sing Boulevard of Broken Dreams in the Secret Santa episode. What are you trying to tell me, Jenna? What is happening? Is this an episode of Lost?
当他向你展示音乐功能如何工作时，他播放了绿日乐队的歌曲《破碎梦想大道》。安吉拉，在《办公室》第六季中，德怀特和安迪在《秘密圣诞老人》那一集中唱了《破碎梦想大道》。你想告诉我什么，珍娜？发生了什么？这是《迷失》的一集吗？
Is this an episode of Lost? Group Mind! Group Mind's time portal, what's happening? Is this an episode of Lost? Is this an episode of Lost? Group Mind! Group Mind's time portal. What's happening? I don't know. Don't you think it's crazy that both a video of The Office and that Green Day song were both part of this presentation and then later that same Green Day song shows up on The Office? It's so many coincidences. What's happening?
这是《迷失》的一集吗？集体思维！集体思维的时间之门，发生了什么？这是《迷失》的一集吗？这是《迷失》的一集吗？集体思维！集体思维的时间之门。发生了什么？我不知道。你不觉得很疯狂吗？《办公室》的视频和那首绿日乐队的歌都是那次演讲的一部分，然后后来同一首绿日乐队的歌出现在了《办公室》里？太多的巧合了。发生了什么？
I think it's a collective of amazing creative minds. It's a group mind of great stuff. You've got an iPhone. You've got a computer. You've got a computer. You've got a computer. It's so many coincidences. What's happening? I think it's a collective of amazing creative minds. It's a great mind of great stuff. You've got an iPhone, you've got the office, you've got green day. It's great mind. I don't know. Okay.
我认为这是一个惊人的创造性思维的集合。这是一个伟大东西的集体思维。你有iPhone。你有电脑。你有电脑。你有电脑。太多的巧合了。发生了什么？我认为这是一个惊人的创造性思维的集合。这是一个伟大东西的伟大思维。你有iPhone，你有《办公室》，你有绿日。这是伟大的思维。我不知道。好的。
All right. What's next, Jenna? Fast fact number three. There are a ton of talking heads in this episode. Did you notice? Well, yeah, because everyone's reacting. I did notice that. Everyone's talking about, oh, what am I going to do now that the branch is closing?
好了。接下来是什么，珍娜？速记事实三号。这一集里有大量的采访镜头。你注意到了吗？嗯，是的，因为每个人都在反应。我确实注意到了。每个人都在谈论，哦，分部要关闭了，我现在该怎么办？
And then when we find out the branch is not closing, everybody talks about, oh, here's my reaction to that news. Do you remember when we talked about how our cinematographer, Randall Einhorn, chose the placement of a talking head based on whether or not people had a future outside of Dunder Mifflin? Yes. To refresh everyone's memories, we learned that most characters have the office of Dunder Mifflin
然后当我们发现分部没有关闭时，每个人都在谈论，哦，这是我对那个消息的反应。你还记得我们谈论过我们的摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩是如何根据人们在邓德·米夫林之外是否有未来来选择采访镜头的位置吗？是的。为了唤起大家的记忆，我们了解到大多数角色在进行采访镜头时，
behind them, behind them in that window, as they're giving their talking heads. And the reason behind this was that that meant people were stuck. They didn't really have a future. They were kind of stuck in the world of Dunder Mifflin. Right. However, very often Jim would have a talking head all the time.
邓德·米夫林的办公室都在他们身后，在那个窗户后面。背后的原因是这意味着人们被困住了。他们真的没有未来。他们有点被困在邓德·米夫林的世界里了。对。然而，吉姆经常一直有采访镜头。
And his talking heads had a window to the world behind him. Yes. The point of that was because he had a future outside of this company. He was going places. Yes. Angela, He was going places. Yes. Angela, in this episode, after the employees get the news that Dunder Mifflin Scranton
他的采访镜头后面有一扇通向世界的窗户。是的。那一点的原因是因为他在公司之外有未来。他前途无量。是的。安吉拉，他在这一集中，在员工们得到邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿
is closing, every single one of the talking heads have a window to the outside world behind them. No, they don't. Oh, yes, they do. Wait. When they find out that the branch isn't closing, all of the talking heads switch back to having the bullpen behind them. I did not catch that.
要关闭的消息后，每一个采访镜头后面都有一扇通向外部世界的窗户。不，他们没有。哦，是的，他们有。等等。当他们发现分部没有关闭时，所有的采访镜头都切换回了办公区在他们身后。我没注意到这一点。
You have to watch it. I have to go back and watch it. Angela, you have a talking head where you're talking about Dunder Mifflin closing and outside world behind you. Same with Pam, same with Ryan, same with Phyllis, same with Stanley. And then when we find out that we're still stuck at Dunder Mifflin, Dunder Mifflin is behind us. That is so wild because I really don't think
你必须看一看。我得回去看一看。安吉拉，你有一个采访镜头，你在谈论邓德·米夫林关闭，外面世界在你身后。帕姆也是，瑞安也是，菲利斯也是，斯坦利也是。然后当我们发现我们仍然被困在邓德·米夫林时，邓德·米夫林就在我们身后。这太疯狂了，因为我真的不认为
I ever had talking heads on that wall. I mean, I'm trying to think back, I think maybe one time when I was sitting next to you when we were both pregnant, right? Yeah. But like, wow, Jenna, that is a fantastic fast fact. It's subtle, but it's layered and it's there. Everybody watch branch closing again,
我曾经在那面墙上有过采访镜头。我的意思是，我试着回想，我想也许有一次当我坐在你旁边，我们都怀孕的时候，对吧？是的。但，哇，珍娜，这是一个很棒的速记事实。它很微妙，但它有层次，而且它就在那里。大家再看一遍《分部关闭》，
just for the talking head. That's it, that's what I got. I'm giving you some claps all around. I was really proud of that one because I tracked that one myself. So I'm giving myself a real pat on the back for that. I'm raising my glass to myself. I don't know if you can see, I'm raising my coffee mug to myself. So I'm giving myself a real pat on the back for that. I'm raising my glass to myself. I don't know if you can see. I'm raising my coffee mug to myself.
就为了采访镜头。就是这样，这就是我得到的。我为你鼓掌。我真的很为那个感到自豪，因为那是我自己追踪到的。所以我真的在给自己拍拍背。我正在为自己举杯。我不知道你能不能看到，我正在为自己举起咖啡杯。所以我真的在给自己拍拍背。我正在为自己举杯。我不知道你能不能看到。我正在为自己举起咖啡杯。
I'm raising mine back to you. You do as you raise your coffee mug. I notice you have a tattoo on your wrist that you normally don't have. I was fascinated and fixated on it. Did your kids give you a sticky tattoo? You know, Angela, in this pandemic, we have brought back some real oldies but goodies at our house. And one of them has been the temporary tattoos. This is something my kids were interested in when they were like two or three years old and they're now eight and six. And we found this drawer of temporary tattoos and we're tatting up.
我也为你举杯。你举起咖啡杯的时候，我注意到你的手腕上有一个纹身，你平时没有。我被它迷住了，盯着它看。是你孩子给你贴的粘性纹身吗？你知道，安吉拉，在这个大流行期间，我们在家里带回了一些真正的老古董，但很好。其中之一就是临时纹身。这是我孩子在两三岁时感兴趣的东西，他们现在八岁和六岁了。我们发现了这个临时纹身的抽屉，我们正在纹身。
You know what we found? Why? As exciting as your tattoos. We found in the shed a bin of unopened Play-Doh. And it was still good. Our kids are 12, 12 and 10. They're not, you know, that's when you sort of phase out a Play-Doh. You brought it back. There's a chicken that poops Play-Doh. It's made a comeback.
你知道我们发现了什么吗？为什么？和你的一样令人兴奋。我们在棚子里发现了一个没开封的培乐多泥。而且它还是好的。我们的孩子是12岁、12岁和10岁。他们不是，你知道，那是你有点不再玩培乐多泥的时候。你把它带回来了。有一只鸡会拉培乐多泥。它卷土重来了。
Lady, those fast facts were so good. I mean, where do we go from there? We should probably take a break. Let's take a break and then we'll dive into this episode. It sounds great. Hey, what's up, Flies? This is David Spade. Dana Carvey.
女士，那些速记事实太棒了。我的意思是，我们从那里去哪里？我们可能应该休息一下。让我们休息一下，然后我们将深入探讨这一集。听起来不错。嘿，怎么了，苍蝇们？这是大卫·斯佩德。达纳·卡维。
Look, I know we never actually left, but I'll just say it. We are back with another season of Fly on the Wall. Every episode, including ones with guests, will now be on video. Every Thursday you'll hear us and see us chatting with big name celebrities. And every Monday you're stuck with just me and Dana. We react to news, what's trending, viral clips. Follow and listen to Fly on the Wall everywhere you get your podcasts.
听着，我知道我们从未真正离开，但我只想说。我们带着《墙上的苍蝇》的另一季回来了。每一集，包括有嘉宾的剧集，现在都将有视频。每周四你都会听到并看到我们与大牌名人的聊天。每周一你只能忍受我和达纳。我们对新闻、趋势、病毒式剪辑做出反应。在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听《墙上的苍蝇》。
["Fly on the Wall"] All right, we're back guys. We're gonna start breaking down this episode of Branch Closing. We're gonna start with that cold open that we told you ran during the unveiling of the iPhone. Yeah, so this is a classic Jim prank. Ben that we told you ran during the unveiling of the iPhone. Yeah. So this is a classic Jim prank.
["墙上的苍蝇"] 好了，我们回来了，伙计们。我们要开始解析这一集的《分部关闭》了。我们要从那个我们告诉过你们在iPhone揭幕期间播放的冷开场开始。是的，所以这是一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。我们告诉过你们在iPhone揭幕期间播放的。是的。所以这是一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。
He has found a way to prank Dwight even from the Stanford branch. He is sending a fax very early in the morning. Karen enters. She's a little curious, like, what are you doing? And he's like, it's too hard to explain. And we see a talking head where Jim says that he stole some of Dwight's stationery before he left, and he occasionally sends Dwight effects from Dwight's future self. It's so good.
他找到了一种即使从斯坦福分部也能恶作剧德怀特的方法。他一大早就发传真。凯伦进来了。她有点好奇，就像，你在做什么？他说这太难解释了。我们看到一个采访镜头，吉姆说他在离开前偷了一些德怀特的信纸，他偶尔会从德怀特的未来自我那里给德怀特发传真。太棒了。
It's so perfect. It's so perfect. And that morning he said, don't drink the coffee, might be poisoned, right? Something to that effect. So Dwight's like, oh my God. And he sees Stanley about to take a sip of coffee and he, you know, practically tackles him to the ground. He's like, you'll thank me later. So Dwight thinks he is getting faxes from his future self.
太完美了。太完美了。那天早上他说，别喝咖啡，可能有毒，对吧？类似的意思。所以德怀特就像，哦，天哪。他看到斯坦利正要喝咖啡，他，你知道，几乎把他扑倒在地。他说，你以后会感谢我的。所以德怀特认为他正在收到来自他未来自我的传真。
This is classic Jim. It's so good. It's so good. The first thing I thought after I watched this cold open was, did Mike Schur write this episode? He did, because that's Mike Schur. This is 100% from the brain of Mike Schur write this episode? He did, because that's Mike Schur. This is 100% from the brain of Mike Schur. He did such a good job of writing these Jim Dwight pranks.
这是经典的吉姆。太棒了。太棒了。看完这个冷开场后，我首先想到的是，迈克·舒尔写了这一集吗？他写了，因为那是迈克·舒尔。这100%来自迈克·舒尔的大脑。他写了这一集吗？他写了，因为那是迈克·舒尔。这100%来自迈克·舒尔的大脑。他在编写这些吉姆和德怀特的恶作剧方面做得太好了。
Oh, he's so smart, Jenna. He's so smart. I know. Smarty. Yeah. All right, so then we move into the episode and Michael is at his desk. Jan enters. Oh, Michael.
哦，他太聪明了，珍娜。他太聪明了。我知道。聪明鬼。是的。好了，然后我们进入这一集，迈克尔在他的办公桌前。简进来了。哦，迈克尔。
Again, like three hellos. Just call me Levinson in the morning. In the morning, Levinson's. And you know, Jan has news to deliver. But first she has to sit through this barrage of awkward hellos from Michael, and she finally tells him, Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing.
又是三个问候。早上直接叫我莱文森就行了。早上，莱文森的。你知道，简有消息要传达。但首先她必须忍受迈克尔这一连串尴尬的问候，她终于告诉他，邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿分部要关闭了。
You are a Severance Package person. Yeah, you're not going to make it. Michael starts crying. And then he starts like moaning. Like how awkward, Jenna, could you imagine, like in this moment? No, and of course it's so loud, everyone from outside the office can see and hear that something is going down in his office.
你是一个遣散费的人。是的，你撑不过去了。迈克尔开始哭泣。然后他开始像呻吟。多尴尬啊，珍娜，你能想象吗，在这一刻？不，当然声音太大了，办公室外面的每个人都能看到并听到他的办公室里发生了什么。
Everyone's very curious. Yes, because he's like, ugh. Like, he's moaning. Kevin comes over to Pam's desk, wants to know what's going on. We had a fan question. OK, I'm going to let this fan question go. And then I have a card that just says, what? Is it what Hadley Horton is wondering why is Pam's
每个人都很好奇。是的，因为他就像，呃。就像，他在呻吟。凯文走到帕姆的办公桌前，想知道发生了什么。我们有一个粉丝问题。好的，我要让这个粉丝问题过去。然后我有一张卡片，上面只写着，什么？是哈德利·霍顿在想为什么帕姆的
hair different what's up with the low pony oh that's a separate card called low pony question mark okay where should we start should we start with what or low pony let's start with what and then go into low pony. Great. Pam calls Kevin Kev and then Buddy and they fist bump. What is happening? What is happening? The fist bump was a reluctant fist bump though, Ange. I know, but Kev, Buddy, fist bump. She's being condescending.
头发不一样，低马尾是怎么回事？哦，那是一张单独的卡片，叫低马尾问号。好的，我们应该从哪里开始？我们应该从“什么”开始，还是从低马尾开始？让我们从“什么”开始，然后进入低马尾。太棒了。帕姆叫凯文“凯夫”，然后是“哥们”，他们碰拳。发生了什么？发生了什么？碰拳是一个不情愿的碰拳，安吉。我知道，但凯夫，哥们，碰拳。她在表现得居高临下。
She's being totally condescending. She's trying to put him off. She's like Kev, Buddy, fist bump, leave my desk. I mean, she's trying to get through it. That's my interpretation. My interpretation was that he's like a little kid. Yeah. Yeah.
她完全是在居高临下。她想打发他走。她就像凯夫，哥们，碰拳，离开我的办公桌。我的意思是，她想度过难关。这是我的解读。我的解读是，他就像个小孩子。是的。是的。
So she's like, OK, Kev. So she's patronizing him, for sure. But you just don't often hear Pam sort of become that casual with Kevin. I feel like she saves that part of herself for Jim and everyone else she's sort of just aloof to a little bit. So it just kind of was startling to me. That and your low ponytail, I mean, what the heck?
所以她就像，好的，凯夫。所以她肯定是在屈尊俯就他。但你并不经常听到帕姆对凯文变得那么随意。我觉得她把那部分自己留给了吉姆，而对其他人她只是有点冷漠。所以这对我来说有点令人吃惊。那个和你的低马尾，我的意思是，到底怎么回事？
Here's the deal with the low pony. I think it was a swing and a miss. I wasn't crazy about it when I saw it. We were trying to change things up. You might notice as well, I wasn't crazy about it when I saw it. We were trying to change things up. You might notice as well, Pam has got a little bit of like a pinkier, sparklier eyeshadow on in this episode as well and a little lip gloss. There's so much pink.
关于低马尾，情况是这样的。我觉得那是一次失败的尝试。我看到它时并不太喜欢。我们试图改变一下。你可能也会注意到，我看到它时并不太喜欢。我们试图改变一下。你可能也会注意到，帕姆在这一集里也涂了一点粉色、闪亮的眼影，还有一点唇彩。粉色太多了。
She has pink eyeshadow, pink lipstick, pink sweater, but then the low pony with the clip. Not even a ponytail holder. I can't wait. Wait, I sounded so Southern. It's very hard for me. Holder. Anyway, it's a clip holding your hair, not even a ponytail holder. Yeah.
她有粉色眼影，粉色口红，粉色毛衣，但还有那个带夹子的低马尾。甚至不是马尾辫圈。我等不及了。等等，我听起来太南方了。这对我来说很难。圈。总之，是一个夹子夹着你的头发，甚至不是马尾辫圈。是的。
Well, the clip is humongous. Here's the thing. The conversation in hair and makeup was that Pam would be experimenting a little bit because she's going to her art classes, she's living on her own. We needed to see some physical representation of the fact that she's attempting even in small ways to break out of her shell right now,
好吧，那个夹子太巨大了。事情是这样的。发型和化妆的对话是，帕姆会尝试一点改变，因为她要去上艺术课，她自己住。我们需要看到一些身体上的表现，证明她正在尝试，即使是以小方式，打破她现在的外壳，
to break out of her routines. So there you go, We offer the low pony. I'm gonna say, I think you never see it again because it wasn't great. Can we just say it wasn't great? It's a clip low pony. Yeah. A clip low pony. Now I kind of wish they'd really gone for it.
打破她的常规。所以就这样，我们提供了低马尾。我要说，我觉得你再也看不到它了，因为它并不好。我们能直接说它并不好吗？这是一个夹子低马尾。是的。一个夹子低马尾。现在我有点希望他们真的尝试过了。
Next week you would have had a banana clip. Remember those things? Oh God. They gave you like a mohawk? Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, it was a moment in time. It was something we tried.
下周你就会有一个香蕉夹了。记得那些东西吗？哦，天哪。他们给了你一个莫霍克发型？是的。是的。好了。好吧，那是那一刻的时刻。那是我们尝试过的事情。
Unfortunately, it's there for us all to see again and again. OK, don't say unfortunately to me. Do you see how many low ponies my character has? Like all the crazy hair he's got? I don't have a problem with a low pony. I don't have a problem with a low pony. I don't have a problem with a low pony in general. I'm just saying this particular low pony was because of the giant clip, it was odd. We're back in Michael's office.
不幸的是，它在那里供我们所有人一次又一次地看到。好的，别对我说不幸。你看到我的角色有多少低马尾了吗？就像他所有的疯狂头发？我对低马尾没有问题。我对低马尾没有问题。我对低马尾没有问题。我只是说这个特定的低马尾是因为那个巨大的夹子，它很奇怪。我们回到迈克尔的办公室。
And Jenna, I don't know if you've ever had to fire someone I have or if you've ever been fired, but I couldn't imagine getting the news Michael got. And Jan's like, well, you know, they believe that Josh Porter is going to have a big role in the future of the company. And Michael goes, what kind of role? The king of the stupid universe? Just like, could you imagine?
珍娜，我不知道你是否曾经不得不解雇某人，我有，或者你是否曾经被解雇，但我无法想象得到迈克尔得到的消息。简说，嗯，你知道，他们相信乔什·波特在公司的未来中会扮演重要角色。迈克尔说，什么样的角色？愚蠢宇宙的国王？就像，你能想象吗？
Like, firing someone, basically, who's having this kind of a spiral. I mean. Could you imagine firing someone, basically, who's having this kind of a spiral. I mean... Could you imagine firing someone or being fired and then having their wind-up mechanical teeth go off? Was that in the script? It was an accident. And by the way, this points to what amazing actors Steve and Melora are,
就像，解雇某人，基本上，正在经历这种螺旋式下降的人。我的意思是。你能想象解雇某人或被解雇，然后他们的发条机械牙齿响了吗？那在剧本里吗？那是一个意外。顺便说一句，这指出了史蒂夫和梅洛拉是多么了不起的演员，
because they just stayed in the moment and reacted to it as if that was meant to happen. It was not meant to happen. It was not meant to happen. That's brilliant. And could it be more brilliant that you're firing this guy who's so incompetent on so many levels and his clacky teeth go off? Yes. Amazing. All right. I'm going to move us along. Michael has a talking head where he says, let's see Josh find another Stanley, Phyllis or Kevin. Show me that farm.
因为他们只是留在那一刻，并对此做出反应，好像那是注定要发生的。那不是注定要发生的。那不是注定要发生的。那太棒了。还有什么比解雇这个在很多层面上都如此无能的家伙，而他的咔哒牙齿响起来更棒的呢？是的。太棒了。好了。我要带我们继续前进。迈克尔有一个采访镜头，他说，让我们看看乔什能不能找到另一个斯坦利、菲利斯或凯文。给我看那个农场。
Show me that farm. And during that talking head, we kind of, we see Creed eating his mung beans at his desk. We see Phyllis knitting. And we had a fan question from Stephanie Miller. In this episode, when we see Phyllis knitting, can she knit in real life? Did she knit that whole scarf her character is working on?
给我看那个农场。在那个采访镜头中，我们看到克里德在他的办公桌前吃他的绿豆。我们看到菲利斯在织毛衣。我们有一个来自斯蒂芬妮·米勒的粉丝问题。在这一集中，当我们看到菲利斯织毛衣时，她在现实生活中会织毛衣吗？她织了她角色正在做的整条围巾吗？
You guys, she is 100% fake knitting. Phyllis cannot knit. Didn't she do so good? They had a basket full of knitting stuff. They'd made it part of her character. It's set next to her desk all nine seasons. And it just sat there. And sometimes if she had to do background stuff,
伙计们，她是100%假织。菲利斯不会织毛衣。她做得不是很好吗？他们有一个装满编织东西的篮子。他们把它变成了她角色的一部分。它在所有九季里都放在她的办公桌旁边。它就放在那里。有时如果她必须做背景工作，
but this was a great panning shot because, you know, Michael says there is no Stanley tree and he's napping. And then they say, do you think the world is crawling with Phyllis's and she's knitting? So it was this great visual, but no, Phyllis can't knit. Yeah, no, no. That's one of my favorite talking heads though.
但这真是一个很棒的平移镜头，因为，你知道，迈克尔说没有斯坦利树，他在打瞌睡。然后他们说，你认为世界到处都是菲利斯吗，她在织毛衣？所以这是一个很棒的视觉效果，但不，菲利斯不会织毛衣。是的，不，不。不过那是我最喜欢的采访镜头之一。
I love that one. I do too. I do too. So then Michael is walking around the office. Dwight can tell something's wrong, but Michael isn't spilling. And this is my other favorite talking head from this episode, which is Dwight's talking head, where he says when you're close to someone, you can read them like a book. And he says, Michael's book is titled, Something Weird is Going On, colon, What Did Jan Say?
我也喜欢那个。我也喜欢。然后迈克尔在办公室里走来走去。德怀特能看出有什么不对劲，但迈克尔没有透露。这是我这一集中另一个最喜欢的采访镜头，也就是德怀特的采访镜头，他说当你和某人很亲近时，你可以像读一本书一样读懂他们。他说，迈克尔的书标题是《奇怪的事情正在发生》，冒号，简说了什么？
The Michael Scott Story by Michael Scott with Dwight Schrute. All right, that last part is not in the script and I could kind of tell that there was an improv there because whenever Rain improvs at the end of a talking head or the end of a scene, I feel like you can see him smile just a little bit in the corners of his mouth and his eyes. So I reached out to Mike Schur and he told me
《迈克尔·斯科特的故事》，作者迈克尔·斯科特，德怀特·施鲁特。好了，最后那部分不在剧本里，我能看出那里有即兴表演，因为每当雷恩在采访镜头结束或场景结束时即兴表演，我觉得你都能看到他在嘴角和眼睛里微微一笑。所以我联系了迈克·舒尔，他告诉我
that he and Rain expanded on the book title on the day on set, They kept throwing out ideas. The original was just supposed to be something weird is going on, colon what did Jan say? And Mike threw out the Michael Scott story and then Rain added with Dwight Schrute. Yeah, for sure. I mean, I feel like we all have tells
他和雷恩在片场当天扩展了书名，他们一直在抛出想法。原版只是应该是《奇怪的事情正在发生》，冒号，简说了什么？迈克抛出了《迈克尔·斯科特的故事》，然后雷恩加上了“德怀特·施鲁特”。是的，当然。我的意思是，我觉得我们都有暗示，
and Rain, when he has an improv that I think he's really happy with has a little bit of a smirk. He's kind of proud of the moment. He amuses himself in the moment while saying it. Now things are really getting heightened over at the Stanford branch because Karen breaks the news that the Scranton branch is closing to Jim and oh my God, Jim's face. He's like, what?
雷恩，当他有一个他认为自己真的很满意的即兴表演时，会有一点窃笑。他为那一刻感到自豪。他在说的时候在那一刻自娱自乐。现在斯坦福分部的事情真的变得更加紧张了，因为凯伦向吉姆透露了斯克兰顿分部要关闭的消息，哦，天哪，吉姆的脸。他就像，什么？
You notice he doesn't reach out to Pam. Pam and Jim never call one another or text one another in this whole day. It's kind of weird because in Diwali, we see that Pam was texting Jim and they had that phone call at the end of grief counseling. But what's going on? Why no communication? It makes perfect sense to me.
你注意到他没有联系帕姆。帕姆和吉姆在这一整天里从来没有互相打电话或发短信。这有点奇怪，因为在《排灯节》里，我们看到帕姆在给吉姆发短信，他们在《悲伤辅导》结束时有那个电话。但发生了什么？为什么没有沟通？这对我来说很有意义。
You know, they're both sort of struggling with where do we go from here? And I'm sure Pam's first instinct is to reach out to him, but she doesn't feel like she has that kind of access to him anymore. She rejected him. So no, it makes perfect sense to me that they don't communicate. What I thought was weirder, and we're going to get to it, is that Roy finds out from accounting. So Pam didn't even tell Roy.
你知道，他们都在某种程度上挣扎着我们从这里去哪里？我相信帕姆的第一直觉是联系他，但她觉得她不再有那种接触他的途径了。她拒绝了他。所以不，他们不沟通对我来说很有意义。我以为更奇怪的是，我们要讲到它，是罗伊从会计那里发现的。所以帕姆甚至没有告诉罗伊。
That's right. So now Michael approaches Pam at front reception. He's acting really strange. She clearly knows something is up, because he was moaning in his office and Jan visited. So Pam's like, what's going on, Michael? Yeah, I have a fan catch from this moment. OK. on, Michael? Yeah, I have a fan catch from this moment. Okay. At 6 minutes 21 seconds,
没错。所以现在迈克尔在前台接近帕姆。他表现得很奇怪。她显然知道发生了什么，因为他在办公室里呻吟，简来访了。所以帕姆就像，发生了什么，迈克尔？是的，我从这一刻得到了一个粉丝捕捉。好的。发生了什么，迈克尔？是的，我从这一刻得到了一个粉丝捕捉。好的。在6分21秒，
Celeste Dimas says, if you freeze and look closely on that big board that's hanging by accounting, on Tuesday the 5th, it says, one of many Emmys, Steve was robbed. Oh, that's a great fan catch. I promise I didn't write it. We shot this episode about two weeks after the Emmys and I guess someone had written up on the board a little congratulations to us and we also needed to say that Steve was robbed because he did not win that year for Michael Scott. He never won for Michael Scott. Which is ridiculous. Yeah. Well, I have a Jenna catch because since Celeste turned me on to looking at this whiteboard, I found something else on the whiteboard. On the top line written under Thursday, written in multiple colors, it says, in case you haven't noticed, there is a lot of colorful hooey on this board. Anyway, guys, for the future, I think it could be very fun to freeze on this whiteboard because
塞莱斯特·迪马斯说，如果你冻结并仔细看挂在会计旁边的那个大板子，在周二5号，上面写着，众多艾美奖之一，史蒂夫被抢劫了。哦，那是一个很棒的粉丝捕捉。我保证我没写它。我们在艾美奖后大约两周拍摄了这一集，我想有人在板子上写了一点对我们的祝贺，我们也需要说史蒂夫被抢劫了，因为他那年没有因为迈克尔·斯科特获奖。他从来没有因为迈克尔·斯科特获奖。这太荒谬了。是的。好吧，我有一个珍娜捕捉，因为自从塞莱斯特让我看这个白板后，我在白板上发现了别的东西。在周四下面写的第一行，用多种颜色写着，以防你没注意到，这个板子上有很多多彩的胡言乱语。总之，伙计们，为了未来，我觉得冻结在这个白板上会很有趣，因为
they did change what they wrote all the time. Well, I love that. I love the little subtle shade towards the television academy about Steve not getting the Emmy. Totally. Coming up next, Michael has a talking head, and then he does something immediately after. And it's one of these classic Michael moments that I live for. It always makes me laugh so hard.
他们总是改变他们写的东西。好吧，我喜欢那个。我喜欢对电视学院关于史蒂夫没得到艾美奖的一点微妙的讽刺。完全是。接下来，迈克尔有一个采访镜头，然后他在之后立即做了一些事情。这是我为之活着的经典迈克尔时刻之一。它总是让我笑得那么厉害。
Michael says that all he can do is put on a brave face and be our leader. And then he says to the whole bullpen, it's over. We are screwed. Yeah. Really, buddy? That's the brave face you're putting on for us?
迈克尔说他唯一能做的就是强颜欢笑，做我们的领导。然后他对整个办公室的人说，一切都结束了。我们完蛋了。是啊。真的吗，伙计？这就是你为我们表现出的强颜欢笑吗？
Okay, thanks. Yeah. I mean, he really, he offers no comfort. He sort of begins to ugly cry. Angela is asking about the employees, asking about their jobs. I have two catches here. I have something I need to say, Angela. Okay, go.
好的，谢谢。是啊。我的意思是，他真的，他没有提供任何安慰。他开始有点难看地哭了起来。安吉拉在询问员工的情况，询问他们的工作。我这里有两个发现。安吉拉，我有话要说。好的，说吧。
At seven minutes, 18 seconds, your sweater? It's a sweater vest. OK, so I actually have some photos of this sweater from a wardrobe fitting that I saved. So I have a button-down shirt, and then over it I have a sweater vest, but it's like a tank? It's a teeny tiny, very odd sweater vest. Yes. It's like another one of those failed project runway contests.
在7分18秒，你的毛衣？那是件毛衣背心。好吧，其实我保存了一些试装时拍的这件毛衣的照片。我穿了一件扣领衬衫，外面套了一件毛衣背心，但它看起来像个背心？那是一件非常小、非常奇怪的毛衣背心。是的。它就像是《决战时装伸展台》里那些失败的作品之一。
Oh, a hundred percent. And then our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, took the buttons off the sweater vest and replaced them with those cat faces. It's really a work of art. It really is. All right, well, I have a catch. At seven minutes, 27 seconds,
哦，百分之百是。然后我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特把毛衣背心上的扣子拆掉，换成了那些猫脸扣子。这真是一件艺术品。确实是。好吧，我有一个发现。在7分27秒，
this is one of the most famous Michael Scott memes. It's Steve making that face, like he's about to cry or maybe he smells dog poop, you know the face. And he says, this is the worst. And people use it a ton to respond to other people. Like when they get some news that they're like, no way. All of a sudden I see in my feed Steve's face. Okay, on Office Ladies Pod,
这是迈克尔·斯科特最著名的表情包之一。那是史蒂夫做的那个表情，好像他快要哭了，或者可能他闻到了狗屎味，你知道那个表情。他说，这是最糟糕的。人们经常用它来回复别人。比如当他们收到一些消息，觉得“不会吧”。突然间，我在我的动态里看到了史蒂夫的脸。好的，在《办公室女士》播客上，
will you please post the pictures of your cat buttons and of this meme? Yes, of course, of course. Okay, good. Cause I want everyone to have these visuals. Okay. I think it's important. I have a script question, Jenna, because I know you have the scripts. So Toby admits that he knows that this was going to happen.
你能发布一下你的猫脸扣子和这个表情包的照片吗？当然，当然可以。好的，太好了。因为我想让每个人都能看到这些视觉资料。好的。我觉得这很重要。珍娜，我有一个关于剧本的问题，因为我知道你有剧本。托比承认他知道这件事会发生。
Michael calls him a traitor, says he wants to see him in his office. They start to walk in and Michael says, oh my God, you walk so slowly. I feel like that was Steve improvising. I had that same feeling and I did look at the script. None of that part of him calling Toby into his office was scripted. So him, that whole bit of him calling Toby in his office, say he's walking slowly and then Dwight guarding the door and putting his hand up to the camera, none of that was in the script. Amazing. Amazing. And I love that everyone just went with it. They just were like, oh, Steve's doing his thing. We're going to let this play out and participate.
迈克尔叫他叛徒，说要在办公室见他。他们开始走进去，迈克尔说，天哪，你走得太慢了。我觉得那是史蒂夫即兴发挥的。我有同样的感觉，我确实看了剧本。他叫托比进办公室的那部分完全没有剧本。所以他叫托比进办公室、说他走得慢，然后德怀特守在门口并把手伸向镜头，这些全都不在剧本里。太棒了。太棒了。而且我喜欢每个人都顺着他演。他们只是觉得，哦，史蒂夫在做他的事。我们要让它继续下去并参与其中。
Because I looked, I was like, wait, is there a lost scene of Toby in Michael's office? Is there a conversation that didn't make it? No, no, that was just Steve on the day. Wow. And you know, speaking of how Rain gets the little smirk when he improvises, at 7 minutes 52 seconds, when he won't let the camera crew in and he shuts the door, he has the smirk. I noticed it too. Uh huh. Well, we had a fan question from Mary Poulton and actually a lot of people wrote in with
因为我查过了，我在想，等等，是不是有一段托比在迈克尔办公室的遗失场景？是不是有一段没播出的对话？不，不，那只是史蒂夫当天的即兴发挥。哇。说到雷恩即兴发挥时那种小窃笑，在7分52秒，当他不让摄制组进去并关上门时，他露出了那种窃笑。我也注意到了。嗯哼。好吧，我们有一个来自玛丽·波尔顿的粉丝提问，其实很多人都写信问了
a similar question. She wanted to know, when we got the script for this episode, did any of us worry that the show was being canceled, or did we know that this was just an idea for an episode? And she was asking, and a lot of people were asking, because we've said before, sometimes plots are revealed to us at these table reads, and they were shocking. And they wanted to know, as we sat down and got the script, as we were reading it, were we thinking, wait a second, what? Scranton's closing. Are we all out of jobs?
类似的问题。她想知道，当我们拿到这一集的剧本时，我们中有人担心节目会被取消吗，还是我们知道这只是这一集的一个构思？她问这个问题，是因为很多人都在问，因为我们之前说过，有时情节是在剧本朗读会上才向我们透露的，而且非常令人震惊。他们想知道，当我们坐下来拿到剧本，阅读它的时候，我们是否在想，等一下，什么？斯克兰顿分部要关闭了？我们都失业了吗？
No, guys, we knew that this was a plot point. None of us were worried. We had all had our contracts renewed for all of season three. Yeah. And so we knew that we would be producing 24 episodes in season three. And we also had been tipped off to the fact
不，伙计们，我们知道这只是一个情节转折。我们没人担心。我们所有人的第三季合同都续签了。是啊。所以我们知道我们将在第三季制作24集。而且我们也得到消息说
that eventually there would be a merger episode and that those people from Stanford would be coming to join us. So we didn't have any kind of surprise or anxiety when we got this script. No, we were just excited because it meant finally, after this episode, we could all be in one room together. So we were excited. At least the Scranton branch, we were excited. I don't know. Maybe Stanford was like,
最终会有一集合并的剧情，斯坦福分部的人会来加入我们。所以当我们拿到这个剧本时，我们没有任何惊讶或焦虑。不，我们只是很兴奋，因为这意味着终于，在这一集之后，我们大家可以聚在一个房间里了。所以我们很兴奋。至少斯克兰顿分部的人很兴奋。我不知道。也许斯坦福分部的人会想，
we like our schedule, but we were excited to have everyone back. All right. So now Angela, we move into a Ryan talking head and he's holding up his business cards, right? Or are they his calling cards? Ohhuh. He's holding up his business slash calling card. Uh-huh. Eight minutes. Notice, here it is, talking head exterior window behind him. Oh, nice. This is the beginning of the exterior window talking heads
我们喜欢我们的时间表，但我们很高兴大家能回来。好吧。那么现在安吉拉，我们进入瑞安的采访环节，他拿着他的名片，对吧？还是那是他的社交名片？哦。他拿着他的商务/社交名片。嗯哼。八分钟。注意，就在这儿，采访背景是窗户。哦，不错。这是采访背景出现窗户的开始，
because next up, Angela has a talking head and Kelly has a talking head with the mascara on her face, all exterior windows. She's going to track it. All right. So now we're going back to Stanford and Andy is leading everyone in a chant. Stanford Connecticut.
因为接下来，安吉拉有一次采访，凯利脸上带着睫毛膏也有一次采访，背景都是窗户。她会追踪这个的。好吧。那么现在我们要回到斯坦福分部，安迪正带领大家喊口号。斯坦福，康涅狄格州。
Right? He's getting everyone worked up. So while everyone's chanting at eight minutes, 23 seconds, you will see someone who is beloved by our office casting crew. Her name is Lori Sox. She was our stand-in, her and her husband. Steven, they were like a stand-in duo team. And she's in the background in the scene.
对吧？他让每个人都情绪高涨。所以当大家在8分23秒喊口号时，你会看到一个我们办公室选角团队非常喜爱的人。她的名字叫洛瑞·索克斯。她是我们的替身，她和她的丈夫史蒂芬，他们是一对替身搭档。她在场景的背景里。
And it just made me so happy to see her. I saw her too. I saw her too and I loved it. Well, maybe we should explain what a stand-in is if we haven't before. So after you rehearse a scene with the actors, you bring in people to stand in for the actors while the crew sets the lights and the camera angles.
看到她让我非常开心。我也看到了她。我也看到了她，我喜欢这样。好吧，也许我们应该解释一下什么是替身，如果我们之前没解释过的话。在和演员排练完场景后，你会带人来代替演员，以便工作人员设置灯光和摄像机角度。
And this is an opportunity for the cast to go and get their makeup fixed or change their outfit or any number of things, rehearse their lines. And then when we're ready to start rolling, the actors come back in and stand in their positions or sit at their desks. So Laurie would stand in for all the women and Stephen, her husband, would stand in for the men. But every once in a while, you'll see them pop up in the background of scenes. And that's what happened here. Yeah, they're wonderful. And we all became very close. And anyway, I was very excited
这是演员去补妆、换衣服或做其他事情、排练台词的机会。然后当我们准备好开始拍摄时，演员们回来站在他们的位置上或坐在办公桌前。所以洛瑞会代替所有的女性，而她的丈夫史蒂芬会代替所有的男性。但偶尔，你会看到他们出现在场景的背景中。这就是这里发生的情况。是的，他们很棒。我们大家都变得非常亲近。总之，我非常兴奋
to see her there. I know they were the the loveliest, and they had two kids. Lori got pregnant twice over the course of the show. Everybody who worked on our show became part of the family, and they were part of our family. Yes, absolutely. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith goes into Michael's office to let him know that she is still down to sleep together. She's still down to get down.
能在那儿看到她。我知道他们是最可爱的，他们有两个孩子。洛瑞在节目期间怀孕了两次。每个为我们节目工作的人都成了家庭的一部分，他们也是我们家庭的一部分。是的，绝对是。好吧，回到斯克兰顿，梅雷迪思走进迈克尔的办公室，让他知道她仍然愿意和他发生关系。她仍然愿意“搞定”。
Yeah, because, you know, they made a pact years ago that they would sleep together on the last day of work. And Michael is like, I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay, this storyline, which is going to keep playing out of Meredith trying to figure out who she agreed to have sex with on her last day of work. This was an example of one of the storylines that got cut from the original NBC airing. Oh, okay. So we were able to keep this storyline in
是啊，因为你知道，他们几年前约定过，在工作的最后一天他们会发生关系。而迈克尔却说，我根本不知道你在说什么。好吧，这条故事线，也就是梅雷迪思试图弄清楚她和谁约定在工作最后一天发生性关系，将继续发展。这是从最初NBC播出中剪掉的故事线之一。哦，好吧。所以我们能够把这个故事线保留在
because we got the extra time with the producers cut. Oh my gosh. And see, I love it. I feel like it fills out the picture. Yes, completely. Well, Jenna, your character has a pretty big talking head coming up. You know, it's interesting to see how the branch closing is affecting everyone. Our character has a pretty big talking head coming up.
制片人剪辑版中，因为我们有了额外的时间。天哪。而且你看，我喜欢它。我觉得它让画面更完整了。是的，完全是。好吧，珍娜，你的角色即将有一个相当重要的采访。你知道，看到分部关闭如何影响每个人是很有趣的。我们的角色即将有一个相当重要的采访。
It's interesting to see how the branch closing is affecting everyone. I mean, Stanley is elated, right? He's going to retire early. Oh yeah. Stanley's elated. Ryan says this worked out great. And Pam is really happy. Oh yeah.
看到分部关闭如何影响每个人是很有趣的。我的意思是，斯坦利很高兴，对吧？他要提前退休了。哦，是的。斯坦利很高兴。瑞安说这结果太棒了。帕姆也很高兴。哦，是的。
And we express all of those emotions with an exterior window behind us, Angela. Well, Pam says that she always thought that maybe she would make a big speech and slap someone and storm out. So dramatic. I know. Who would she slap? It would have been me. She would have slapped me. Well, she's eventually going to slap Michael. So maybe that's who she means. But it's definitely going to slap Michael. So maybe that's who she means. But it's definitely either you or Michael. Right? Yeah. Yeah. 100%. Okay. So now Angela, we're over in accounting and Angela and
我们用背景里的窗户表达了所有这些情绪，安吉拉。好吧，帕姆说她一直以为也许她会发表一番慷慨激昂的演讲，扇某人一巴掌，然后冲出去。太戏剧化了。我知道。她会扇谁？那个人会是我。她会扇我。好吧，她最终会扇迈克尔。所以也许她指的是那个人。但绝对是
Kevin break the news to Roy. Yeah. Why? Why do Angela and Kevin break the news? Huh? Why has it said anything? I think this really shows how disconnected Roy and Pam are, by the way. Well, he seems very concerned that Pam might be one of the Connecticut transfers, but Angela kind of misreads his concern and thinks that he's worrying about himself. And she's like, Oh, Roy, you'll be fine. You're so strong and capable. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. You're so strong and capable. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. Yeah, don't worry, Roy.
凯文和安吉拉把这个消息告诉了罗伊。是啊。为什么？为什么是安吉拉和凯文去告诉他？嗯？为什么他没说什么？顺便说一句，我觉得这真的显示了罗伊和帕姆之间有多么脱节。好吧，他似乎非常担心帕姆可能会是去康涅狄格州调职的人之一，但安吉拉有点误解了他的担忧，以为他在担心自己。她说，哦，罗伊，你会没事的。你那么强壮又有能力。是啊，别担心，罗伊。你那么强壮又有能力。是啊，别担心，罗伊。
Kevin finds this hilarious. Angela tells him to grow up. Yeah, he totally storms off. We got a fan question from Patricia Kennedy. Patricia wants to know, Angela, when you're talking to Roy, it seems like Angela has a thing for Roy. Did she?
凯文觉得这很搞笑。安吉拉让他成熟点。是啊，他完全冲走了。我们收到了帕特里夏·肯尼迪的粉丝提问。帕特里夏想知道，安吉拉，当你和罗伊说话时，看起来安吉拉对罗伊有意思。她有吗？
Patricia, this is a fantastic question. All right, many of you out there have speculated about Angela and Roy. Jenna, I have been asked this question a lot, and there's all of these threads online about it. So the answer, Patricia, is yes. It seems like Angela always had a thing for Roy. I love this question, Patricia,
帕特里夏，这是一个非常棒的问题。好吧，你们很多人都猜测过安吉拉和罗伊的事。珍娜，我被问过很多次这个问题，网上也有很多关于这个的帖子。所以答案是，帕特里夏，是的。看起来安吉拉一直对罗伊有意思。我喜欢这个问题，帕特里夏，
because this has given us an opportunity to track it. We're gonna track this Angela-Roy flirtation because it is real and it is happening. All right, early on, there are a few episodes that kind of hint at this Roy-Angela flirtation. I believe it starts in the fire. This is season two. Remember when the members of the office are playing the game, who would you do? And Michael asks Roy, who would you do? And Roy says, what's the name of that tight ass Christian
因为这给了我们一个追踪的机会。我们要追踪这段安吉拉和罗伊的调情，因为它是真实的，而且正在发生。好吧，在早期，有几集暗示了这种罗伊和安吉拉的调情。我相信是从《火灾》那一集开始的。那是第二季。还记得办公室成员在玩“你会和谁发生关系”的游戏吗？迈克尔问罗伊，你会和谁发生关系？罗伊说，那个紧身衣基督徒女孩叫什么名字，那个金发的？
chick, the blonde? Sort of referring to Angela, right? Yeah. And I'm standing right there and I'm like, my name is Angela. And he's like, hey, Angela. So definitely it starts there. And then in The Secret, when Angela and Phyllis are in the kitchen and they're cleaning out the fridge, Phyllis asks Angela who she'd pick if she were in Pam's shoes, Jim or Roy. And Angela's like, oh, I don't want
某种程度上是指安吉拉，对吧？是啊。我就站在那儿，我说，我叫安吉拉。他说，嘿，安吉拉。所以绝对是从那里开始的。然后在《秘密》那一集，当安吉拉和菲利斯在厨房清理冰箱时，菲利斯问安吉拉如果她是帕姆，她会选谁，吉姆还是罗伊。安吉拉说，哦，我不想
to participate in this, right? But then she gets this kind of weird look on her face. And she goes, Roy. Weird look, it's like a confession. It's like, well, Roy. Yeah. But then this just keeps building, right? And it's further fleshed out
参与这个，对吧？但随后她的脸上出现了一种奇怪的表情。她说，罗伊。奇怪的表情，就像是一种坦白。就像是，嗯，罗伊。是啊。但随后这一直在积累，对吧？而且在
in the first ever The Office webisodes, Jenna. Yeah. So the webisodes were called The Books Don't Balance. It featured the accounting department. And if you watch it, go to episode five, titled Someone in the Warehouse. The accountants are wondering if maybe Roy took the missing money.
有史以来第一部《办公室》网络剧集中得到了进一步充实，珍娜。是啊。所以网络剧集叫《账目不平》。它以会计部门为主角。如果你看了，去看第五集，标题是《仓库里的人》。会计们在想罗伊是不是拿走了丢失的钱。
Angela says absolutely not, that he has too much character. And Kevin asked Angela if she has a crush on Roy. And Angela gets very, very flustered. Oh, whoa. She gets so flustered. She like sort of messes up her words, and then she sort of storms off. And you can find this on the DVD set.
安吉拉说绝对没有，他很有品格。凯文问安吉拉是不是暗恋罗伊。安吉拉变得非常、非常慌乱。哦，哇。她变得太慌乱了。她说话有点语无伦次，然后就冲走了。你可以在DVD套装上找到这个。
It's on season two, disc four, as a bonus feature. But yeah, so that happens in the webisodes. OK, well then in season two, Casino Night, there's a scene where Michael addresses the crowd in the casino. And he says, old friends, new lovers. And if you look in the background, Angela and Roy are sitting next to each other at the bar.
它在第二季第四张光盘上，作为奖励内容。但是的，这发生在网络剧集中。好吧，然后在第二季《赌场之夜》，有一个场景是迈克尔在赌场对人群讲话。他说，老朋友，新恋人。如果你看背景，安吉拉和罗伊正坐在吧台边。
And you guys kind of exchange a look. I know. This is one of the things that's been pointed out on the message boards. What's the look between Angela and Roy at casino night when Michael says new lovers? And why are they sitting next to each other? Right? Why are they? I don't know. And then of course in this episode, branch closing, we have the scene at 10 minutes 33 seconds where Angela, like we said, is trying to confront Roy, tells him he's strong and capable. Yes. And then also, if we skip forward to the cocktails episode in season three,
你们俩交换了一个眼神。我知道。这是留言板上指出的事情之一。安吉拉和罗伊在赌场之夜迈克尔说“新恋人”时交换的眼神是什么意思？为什么他们坐在一起？对吧？为什么他们会坐在一起？我不知道。然后当然在这一集《分部关闭》中，我们在10分33秒有一个场景，安吉拉，就像我们说的，试图去面对罗伊，告诉他他很强壮又有能力。是的。然后，如果我们跳到第三季的《鸡尾酒》那一集，
you will briefly hear audio of Roy asking everybody at the bar if they want to drink. And you can hear Angela say something like, oh, no, thank you, Roy. I'm and everybody thinks that maybe that's your character kind of coyly talking to Roy. Yeah, it's kind of odd that it's left in if you watch it because it's off camera and I'm like, oh, no, Roy. And it just kind of trails off. So it's like, what is that about?
你会简短地听到罗伊在吧台问大家要不要喝酒的音频。你可以听到安吉拉说类似“哦，不，谢谢，罗伊”的话，每个人都认为那可能是你的角色在害羞地和罗伊说话。是啊，如果看了的话，留着这个确实有点奇怪，因为那是画外音，我说，哦，不，罗伊。然后它就那样淡出了。所以就像是，那是什么意思？
And then my personal favorite in the episode, The Negotiation, this is also season three, Roy is coming in to get his very last paycheck. And Angela keeps having everyone in the office retell her about the moment Roy tried to attack Jim and Dwight intervened. I mean, there's a scuffle, and she just keeps wanting to hear about the scuffle.
然后是我个人在《谈判》那一集里最喜欢的，这也是第三季，罗伊进来拿他最后一张工资支票。安吉拉一直让办公室里的每个人给她重述罗伊试图攻击吉姆、德怀特介入的那一刻。我的意思是，有一场扭打，她一直想听关于那场扭打的事。
And it seems like she's just as turned on by Dwight's, like being a hero, as hero as by Roy being this aggressive dude. Well, this is Angela, the character's fascination with a sort of alpha male display of, I don't know what you would call it, just testosterone. She loves a big display of testosterone. Yes, don't forget, she mentions that she has had two men have duels over her.
看起来她对德怀特那种英雄行为的兴奋程度，和对罗伊这种好斗男人的兴奋程度是一样的。好吧，这就是安吉拉这个角色对某种阿尔法男性展示的迷恋，我不知道该怎么称呼它，就是睾酮。她喜欢这种大规模的睾酮展示。是的，别忘了，她提到过有两个男人为她决斗过。
Yes, she loves all of this. She loves all of it. Roy is 100% in her wheelhouse. OK, so we've tracked it. But Angela, you went to Greg and to Paul, the writers, to get their intentions behind this whole thing. What did they tell you? Okay, yes. I went to Paul because he wrote the webisodes and it is so plainly spelled out that Angela has a thing for him in those. And I went to Greg as well because I just felt like he had
是的，她喜欢这一切。她喜欢这一切。罗伊百分之百是她的菜。好吧，所以我们追踪到了。但是安吉拉，你去找了格雷格和保罗，那些编剧，去了解他们背后的意图。他们是怎么告诉你的？好吧，是的。我去找了保罗，因为他写了网络剧集，而且在那些剧集里，安吉拉对他有意思表现得非常明显。我也去找了格雷格，因为我觉得他
this overall view of everyone's relationships. This is what Paul said, we never really entertained it going anywhere. We just thought it was funny that Angela liked this rougher, less tolerant guy when the rest of the world was thinking he's kind of a jerk and they're all rooting for Jim. So they sort of liked that foil, right? That I was team Roy. And then this is what Greg said. Greg said Roy and Pam were more of a traditional relationship and Pam needed a more modern equal relationship but it made sense that Angela would be attracted to Roy. It could have turned into something but Roy had to get in line behind Dwight and Andy. I love it. Oh I love it. Alright so then Michael is down in the warehouse he's talking to Daryl.
对每个人的关系有一个整体的看法。保罗是这么说的，我们从来没想过让它有任何发展。我们只是觉得安吉拉喜欢这个更粗鲁、更不宽容的家伙很有趣，而世界上其他人都在想他是个混蛋，都在支持吉姆。所以他们有点喜欢那种对比，对吧？我支持罗伊。然后格雷格是这么说的。格雷格说罗伊和帕姆是更传统的关系，帕姆需要一种更现代、平等的伴侣关系，但安吉拉被罗伊吸引是有道理的。它本可以发展成什么，但罗伊必须排在德怀特和安迪后面。我喜欢这个。哦，我喜欢。好吧，然后迈克尔在仓库里，他在和达里尔说话。
He finds out that Bob Vance has bought the warehouse, and Michael really starts to spin out. And he tells the office he is not going to take this lying down. He and Dwight, they are going to go confront the CFO, and they're going to save the branch. How? What do they think they're going to the branch. How?
他发现鲍勃·万斯买下了仓库，迈克尔真的开始崩溃了。他告诉办公室他不会坐以待毙。他和德怀特，他们要去面对首席财务官，他们要拯救分部。怎么救？他们以为他们要去
What do they think they're gonna do? But I do have an old tech alert, old tech track. What is it? 12 minutes, 50 seconds. Dwight says, hey, he's, you know, David Wallace isn't in the office. Don't worry, I have his home address. And he goes to his flip phone.
做什么？但我有一个旧技术警报，旧技术追踪。是什么？12分50秒。德怀特说，嘿，他，你知道，大卫·华莱士不在办公室。别担心，我有他的家庭住址。然后他拿出了他的翻盖手机。
Jenna, do you see how he has to toggle to find the addresses? Do you remember that? Yes. Oh, and then he says, don't worry, he's on my Christmas card list. I loved this so much, Jenna. I love to think about what is Dwight's Christmas card? What is he sending out? It must be a picture of the beet farm. I feel like it's in some way also a piece of advertising. Maybe it's Moe's holding up a bunch of be beats. I have a fan catch from Nico Martin. When Michael and Dwight are driving to David Wallace's house, the temperature in the car says it's 80 degrees outside. Why are Michael and Dwight wearing
珍娜，你看到他必须切换才能找到地址吗？你记得那个吗？是的。哦，然后他说，别担心，他在我的圣诞贺卡名单上。我太喜欢这个了，珍娜。我喜欢去想德怀特的圣诞贺卡是什么样的？他寄出的是什么？那一定是一张甜菜农场的照片。我觉得它在某种程度上也是一种广告。也许是莫斯举着一堆甜菜。我有一个来自尼科·马丁的粉丝发现。当迈克尔和德怀特开车去大卫·华莱士家时，车里的温度显示外面是80度。为什么迈克尔和德怀特穿着
trench coats? Well, Nico, that's because we shot this episode in August, but it aired on November 9th. And we always tried to match the season in which the episode would air. So that is also why you're going to see pumpkins outside at Davis Wallace's house. We placed them there, even though it was August, to make it seem like it was fall. Yeah, we placed them there
风衣？好吧，尼科，那是因为我们在八月拍摄了这一集，但它是在11月9日播出的。我们总是试图匹配剧集播出的季节。所以这也是为什么你会看到大卫·华莱士家外面有南瓜的原因。我们把它们放在那里，尽管当时是八月，为了让它看起来像是秋天。是的，我们把它们放在那里，
and hoped they wouldn't explode from the heat. Well, let's talk a little bit about the CFO's house, because we got a lot of questions about it. It's a very nice house. We filmed there. I did a few episodes there, and it's a really beautiful home. Well, well, well. I'm rubbing off on you.
并希望它们不会因为高温而爆炸。好吧，让我们谈谈首席财务官的房子，因为我们收到了很多关于它的问题。那是一栋非常漂亮的房子。我们在那里拍摄过。我在那里拍过几集，那是一个非常美丽的家。好吧，好吧，好吧。我被你影响了。
I know. Charlyn Guevara asked, was that someone's actual house or was it random? And Dixie Hydrich said, whose home was used as David Wallace's house and where was it located? Well, of course I went to Kentopedia and he told me that David Wallace's house is located on Lomita Drive in Pasadena, California. It's a beautiful neighborhood. Oh, it's a beautiful neighborhood. It was
我知道。查琳·格瓦拉问，那是某人的真实房子还是随机的？迪克西·海德里奇说，谁的家被用作大卫·华莱士的房子，它位于哪里？好吧，我当然去了肯托百科，他告诉我大卫·华莱士的房子位于加利福尼亚州帕萨迪纳的洛米塔大道。那是一个美丽的社区。哦，那是一个美丽的社区。它
three houses away from the house used on the TV show Benson. That's just a little bit of trivia for it. So just a little bit more about this house. Jennifer Hodge and Whitney Grasick wrote in and said, at 14 minutes, 13 seconds, why does David Wallace have an H monogrammed welcome mat. Shouldn't it be a W? Anna Worthington said, are they at the wrong house? Is that part of the joke? Did Dwight and Michael go to the wrong house and that's why there's an H instead of a W?
离电视剧《本森》中使用的房子只有三栋之遥。这只是一个小小的花絮。关于这栋房子还有一点。詹妮弗·霍奇和惠特尼·格拉西克写信说，在14分13秒，为什么大卫·华莱士有一个印着H的欢迎地垫。不应该是W吗？安娜·沃辛顿说，他们是不是走错房子了？那是笑话的一部分吗？德怀特和迈克尔是不是去了错误的房子，所以那里有一个H而不是W？
Well, Kent told me that it was the doormat of the people who owned the house. No one noticed the mistake until after they were in the editing room. And you'll see in the future, this is David Wallace's house. They just forgot to replace the welcome mat. The welcome mat and also the golden retriever that's in the backyard. Oh no, that's a whole story. That golden retriever was placed there. I'll get to it. Okay. Well, I am intrigued, Jenna. So wrong doormat, but real dog. We'll get to it.
好吧，肯特告诉我那是房主自己的门垫。直到他们在剪辑室时才有人注意到这个错误。你会看到在未来，这就是大卫·华莱士的房子。他们只是忘了更换欢迎地垫。欢迎地垫，还有后院里的那只金毛寻回犬。哦，不，那是一个完整的故事。那只金毛寻回犬是被放在那里的。我会讲到的。好的。好吧，我很好奇，珍娜。所以门垫错了，但狗是真的。我们会讲到的。
Maybe we should take a little break right now. And when we come back, guys, we have a really fun guest. Yeah. All right. We'll see you in a second. All right, guys, we are back and we are in Stamford. And Jan has called Jim and Josh into Josh's office and she announces that Josh will be heading up what is now called Dunder Mifflin Northeast. Jim will be his number two. This is exciting news. Jim is excited until Josh says, Jan, I have actually accepted an offer from Staples.
也许我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，伙计们，我们有一位非常有趣的嘉宾。是啊。好吧，一会儿见。好吧，伙计们，我们回来了，我们在斯坦福。简把吉姆和乔什叫进了乔什的办公室，她宣布乔什将负责现在被称为“邓德·米夫林东北部”的部门。吉姆将是他的二把手。这是令人兴奋的消息。吉姆很兴奋，直到乔什说，简，其实我已经接受了史泰博的录用通知。
Yeah. And he's going to take it. Senior management position at Staples. Jan has ticked off. She's like, you leveraged this new position to get the Staples job when we orchestrated this whole merger just so we could keep you. Yeah. So guys, this is it.
是啊。他要接受它。史泰博的高级管理职位。简很生气。她说，你利用这个新职位去拿史泰博的工作，而我们策划整个合并只是为了留住你。是啊。所以伙计们，就是这样。
This is the last time we see Josh Porter. This character has been with us for three seasons. He first came up in the pilot. We don't see him, but he's mentioned in a scene where Jan and Michael are talking about downsizing. We finally meet him on Valentine's Day, and now he's leaving. And guys, Josh Porter, we've talked about this before, was played by Charles Esten. He appeared in eight episodes of the show.
这是我们最后一次见到乔什·波特。这个角色陪伴了我们三季。他第一次出现在试播集中。我们没见到他，但在简和迈克尔谈论裁员的场景中提到了他。我们最终在情人节见到了他，现在他要离开了。伙计们，乔什·波特，我们之前谈过，是由查尔斯·埃斯滕扮演的。他出现在节目的八集中。
He did a weird pilot with Rainn Wilson. Yes. We never got to work with him, but he's an awesome guy. And to commemorate his time on the show, we reached out to him and we got to chat with him a little bit. All right. we're so excited to have him here. Let's play the interview. Hey, it's Chip. Hey, Chip. Ain't no party like a Scranton party. Because a Scranton party don't stop. So great to see you. Thank you so much. Are you kidding me? It is so great to see you guys. You know how it is. You do a show with somebody and then there's just you don't overlap again and I'm in Nashville now so I haven't been able to see you guys ever since then and all I can say quickly is you could not have been kinder both of you were sincerely the only two nice people there we know yeah
他和一个叫雷恩·威尔逊的人拍过一个奇怪的试播集。是的。我们从没和他一起工作过，但他是个很棒的人。为了纪念他在节目中的时光，我们联系了他，并和他聊了一会儿。好吧。我们很高兴他能来。让我们播放采访。嘿，我是奇普。嘿，奇普。没有像斯克兰顿派对那样的派对。因为斯克兰顿派对不会停止。很高兴见到你。非常感谢。你在开玩笑吗？见到你们真是太好了。你知道是怎么回事。你和某人一起拍节目，然后你们就再也没有交集了，我现在在纳什维尔，所以从那以后我就没能见到你们，我能很快说的是，你们不可能更友善了，你们俩真的是那里仅有的两个好人，我们知道，是啊
everybody was nice but you two were remarkably so considering we had no scenes at all together, you were very, very kind and I appreciated it. We were so excited to have you guys. And we, you know, Jenna and I were talking about this, that we had major FOMO, cause it seemed like all these great stories were coming out of the Stanford branch and funny inside jokes.
每个人都很好，但考虑到我们根本没有对手戏，你们俩非常、非常友善，我很感激。我们很高兴有你们。而且我们，你知道，珍娜和我谈过这个，我们有严重的错失恐惧症，因为看起来所有这些伟大的故事都来自斯坦福分部，还有有趣的内部笑话。
And we were like, dang it, we want to go to Stanford. Well, picture it from the other direction where you're the guy that gets to go be on the office, but you don't get to go in the office. You're on another branch somewhere and you don't get to be with everybody, but you do get to be with Jim and he was awesome. John was fantastic. And you got to wear fancy biker shorts.
我们当时想，该死，我们想去斯坦福。好吧，从另一个方向想象一下，你是那个能去《办公室》工作，但却进不去办公室的人。你在某个地方的另一个分部，你不能和大家在一起，但你确实能和吉姆在一起，他很棒。约翰太棒了。而且你还得穿花哨的骑行短裤。
Those were mine. I just showed up to work in those and yeah, I played the good boss. Well, you know, we've been trying to get ahold of you. Jenna was trying to slide into your DMs, but she must have DMed some other strangers. You are not Chip Esten from Germany. No, I am not. Charles underscore Esten.
那是我的。我只是穿着它们去上班，是的，我扮演了好老板。好吧，你知道，我们一直在试图联系你。珍娜试图滑进你的私信，但她一定私信了其他陌生人。你不是来自德国的奇普·埃斯滕。不，我不是。Charles_Esten。
And I have so many famous leading ladies from classic sitcoms trying to talk to me on Instagram that I have to. Yeah, it's so many. I know. Okay, so we usually ask people on the show their origin story about how they came to be on the office. Like what was their audition process?
而且有这么多经典情景喜剧的著名女主角试图在Instagram上和我说话，我不得不。是啊，太多了。我知道。好吧，所以我们通常会问节目中的人关于他们如何来到《办公室》的起源故事。比如他们的试镜过程是什么样的？
And we would love to hear yours. First of all, I was a British office fan, like so many from the very beginning. So I recall very, very well watching it, loving it all. And then I heard they were trying it in the United States and like a lot of people went, uh-oh, wow. Okay. Good luck. But then I had known, then I heard about Steve and Rain that they had been cast and I was
我们很想听听你的。首先，我从一开始就是英国版《办公室》的粉丝，像许多人一样。所以我记得非常、非常清楚地看着它，喜欢它的一切。然后我听说他们正在美国尝试它，像很多人一样，我想，呃哦，哇。好吧。祝你好运。但后来我听说史蒂夫和雷恩被选中了，我当时想，
like, hmm, that's, that's a heck of a good start. They might have a shot at this. Now, Steve, I don't know how I knew we just knew each other from being in L.A. for a while, I think improv circles, maybe something like that. I don't think we ever worked together, but he's somebody I'd see at the mall. And Sherman Oaks and then anyway, I love it. You say about the mall tracks that tracks for Steve tracks. Steve, Steve used to like talk to Jenna and I about like really good
嗯，那是一个非常好的开始。他们可能真的有机会。现在，史蒂夫，我不知道我是怎么知道的，我们只是因为在洛杉矶待了一段时间而认识，我想是即兴表演圈子，也许是类似的东西。我不认为我们一起工作过，但他是我在商场里会看到的人。在谢尔曼奥克斯，总之，我喜欢它。你说关于商场追踪，那是史蒂夫的追踪。史蒂夫，史蒂夫过去常和珍娜和我谈论他周末发现的真正好的
buys that he found over the weekend. Well, he was working at Brookstone at the time. No, I'm kidding. He wasn't. I was going to be shocked. I was like, this is a piece of trivia I didn't know. Holy moly. He was trying to sell me a massage chair. No, he never as far as I know, he never worked there.
买卖。好吧，他当时在布鲁克通工作。不，我在开玩笑。他没有。我会很震惊的。我当时想，这是一个我不知道的花絮。天哪。他试图卖给我一把按摩椅。不，据我所知，他从没在那里工作过。
Anyway, I would see him. But the way I knew Rainn is the interesting part that got me to the show. Rain and I I'm gonna say six or seven years, it's all a blur before that had been at an audition at NBC, you know, right across from the main place in Burbank was that little casting hut across the street there by the park. And we were reading for this thing called the expendables and the expendables were androids that solved crimes these two guys that's why they were expendable because
总之，我会看到他。但我认识雷恩的方式是让我进入节目的有趣部分。雷恩和我，我要说六七年，在那之前的一切都很模糊，曾在NBC试镜，你知道，就在伯班克主楼对面，公园旁边那个小选角小屋。我们正在为一个叫《敢死队》的东西试镜，敢死队是解决犯罪的机器人，这两个家伙，这就是为什么他们是敢死队，因为
who cares if they get you know you can't beat them you can't defeat them. I know you have to chip I didn't read about this. I did read about this and I got so tickled. So go on go on. So I remember it was pure chance because they literally said you with you you read with you because it was it's two guys and so they they paired us up and somehow just kismet. Rain and I got chosen to be together and I remember forget we went outside and we had the script there was some things to say but we went outside and said let's just have fun with this and by the time we came back in first of all I had
谁在乎他们是否被，你知道，你打不败他们，你无法击败他们。我知道你必须奇普，我没读过这个。我确实读过这个，我被逗乐了。所以继续，继续。所以我记得那是纯粹的偶然，因为他们真的说你和你是搭档，因为它是两个家伙，所以他们把我们配对，不知何故就是缘分。雷恩和我被选中在一起，我记得我们出去了，我们有剧本，有一些话要说，但我们出去了，说让我们享受这个吧，当我们回来时，首先我已经
fallen in love with the guy that is Rain Wilson instantly we just clicked like that I was like I was like, what an incredible guy. What a mind. So we went in there and basically improvised on top of the script and ended up getting the job. And then we all had a table read it NBC right across the street in the big building. I'll never forget there's this long conference table and we're all just reading the script and we're still messing around. We're still just being these two androids and just looking at each other vaguely like... and so somehow we made it funny enough that they they ended up shooting a pilot of it and that's where I really got to hang with them the most. So in any event we shoot that we have a ball it does not get picked up. Shocker! So I get to the
立刻爱上了雷恩·威尔逊这个家伙，我们就像那样一拍即合，我当时想，我当时想，多么不可思议的家伙。多么棒的头脑。所以我们进去了，基本上在剧本之上即兴发挥，最终得到了这份工作。然后我们在街对面的大楼里在NBC进行了一次剧本朗读。我永远不会忘记有一张长会议桌，我们都在读剧本，我们还在胡闹。我们仍然只是这两个机器人，只是模糊地看着对方……所以不知何故我们让它变得足够有趣，他们最终拍摄了一个试播集，那是我真正能和他们相处最多的地方。总之，我们拍摄了那个，我们玩得很开心，它没有被选中。震惊！所以我到了
audition and it's going well I'm doing well enough I guess but I think the separating factor was one of them says so I hear your, I think it was Michael, I hear your friends with Rain and I was like yes I am and I said did Rain ever tell you how we met? And they're like no, I bet he didn And I said, we met playing naked androids on a detective show. And they were both like, they're like. And I said, and on top of that, if you give me this job, I show up day one with a DVD of that pilot.
试镜，进展顺利，我想我做得足够好，但我认为区分因素是其中一个人说，所以我听说你的，我想是迈克尔，我听说你和雷恩是朋友，我当时想，是的，我是，我说雷恩有没有告诉你我们是怎么认识的？他们说没有，我敢打赌他没有。我说，我们是在一部侦探剧里扮演裸体机器人认识的。他们都像，他们像。我说，而且最重要的是，如果你给我这份工作，我第一天就会带着那个试播集的DVD出现。
Oh, nice. Oh. I'm not even to my car. And I'm like, hello? Oh, cool. That's the fastest I ever got a job. So it had nothing to do with my abilities or acting otherwise.
哦，不错。哦。我甚至还没到我的车。我就想，喂？哦，酷。这是我得到过最快的工作。所以这与我的能力或表演无关。
It was purely that I had this on rain. And so that's my origin story. And it's kind of special to me because it's, who could imagine? By that point, I was already a fan. It was like being on, it was like winning a radio contest to be on a show that I already loved
纯粹是因为我抓住了雷恩的把柄。所以这就是我的起源故事。它对我来说很特别，因为，谁能想到呢？到那时，我已经是一个粉丝了。这就像是，这就像赢得了一个电台比赛，能参加一个我已经喜欢的节目
I was very uncool about it because I was just so happy to be there But you guys were all very cool about it So chip after you got the job and you started working on the show we said like it looked like you guys were having so much fun What was it like to get to do these scenes with like Ed Helms and Steve Carell and Rashida Jones? Like do you have have any episodes in particular that you have fond memories of? There is the one episode where Josh is very mad at Jim because Jim is playing Call of Duty
我对此表现得很不酷，因为我只是很高兴能在那儿。但你们都很酷。所以奇普，在你得到这份工作并开始在节目中工作后，我们说看起来你们玩得很开心。和埃德·赫尔姆斯、史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和拉什达·琼斯一起演这些场景是什么感觉？比如你有没有特别有美好回忆的剧集？有一集乔什对吉姆非常生气，因为吉姆在玩《使命召唤》
and uses the sniper rifle and he just starts screaming at him. And of course, Ed was amazing and that scene goes off. And so what I didn't realize is that everybody was playing that game for real on the brakes on the set. Did you guys have that same thing in yours? I believe, right? Yeah. Your computers were actually hooked up and everybody was playing Call of Duty.
并使用了狙击步枪，他开始对他尖叫。当然，埃德很棒，那个场景很精彩。所以我没意识到的是，每个人在片场的休息时间都在玩那个游戏。你们在你们的片场也有同样的情况吗？我相信，对吧？是的。你们的电脑实际上是连在一起的，每个人都在玩《使命召唤》。
So they just wrote it into the show. Everybody I had to I hadn't played that much. I was like, now, what right would they use? And they explained everything to me. And then we went and we we did it. And it was so much fun. Yeah. Yeah. Our writers and editors were really into that. We didn't get to do that on set.
所以他们只是把它写进了节目里。每个人，我没玩过那么多。我当时想，现在，他们会用什么？他们向我解释了一切。然后我们去了，我们做了。这太有趣了。是啊。我们的编剧和剪辑师真的很喜欢那个。我们没能在片场做那个。
We were always a little bummed, but they were playing it all the time. And on the DVD commentary, they did mention that, John mentioned that's like one of the hardest times he had to work not to laugh was in that scene with you and Ed, and you guys were just going off on him about Call of Duty. That's the thing is you're in this business so long and you, and you guys were just going off on him about Call of Duty. That's the thing is you're in this business so long
我们总是有点沮丧，但他们一直在玩。在DVD评论中，他们确实提到了，约翰提到那是他在那一集里最难忍住不笑的时候，就是和你还有埃德的那场戏，你们俩一直在对他大喊大叫关于《使命召唤》的事。这就是问题所在，你在这一行待了这么久，你，你们俩一直在对他大喊大叫关于《使命召唤》的事。这就是问题所在，你在这一行待了这么久
and you're in things that are pretty good, you're in things that are not good at all. And you're always, this funny thing after the show is, I can remember people would walk up to me and go, I saw you on The Office, you're very funny. And I knew that what it really was is I didn't say that many, I wasn't the funny part of, I was more the situation than the comedy,
你参与了一些相当不错的作品，也参与了一些根本不好的作品。你总是，节目结束后一件有趣的事情是，我记得人们会走到我面前说，我在《办公室》里看到你了，你很有趣。我知道真正的情况是我没说那么多，我不是喜剧中好笑的部分，我更多是情境而不是喜剧，
but I did get some great, very, very funny lines. Here, I was just in a room with Ed and John and Rashida and trying not to laugh or just watching Michael Scott when he says, I love inside jokes, like to be a part of one someday. That's just as good a line as anybody can write. And all I had to do was stand there and just do the thing where you don't laugh and you're kind of, you know, the cringe. Um, and I couldn't believe I was, it was thrown. Well, so what is it like for you now? Like the office has had this new life on Netflix and it's everywhere.
但我确实得到了一些很棒、非常、非常有趣的台词。在这里，我只是和埃德、约翰还有拉什达在一个房间里，努力不笑，或者只是看着迈克尔·斯科特，当他说，我喜欢内部笑话，希望有一天能成为其中一员。那和任何人能写的台词一样好。我所要做的就是站在那里，做那种你不笑的动作，你有点，你知道，尴尬。嗯，我不敢相信我被，它被扔了。好吧，那么现在对你来说是什么感觉？《办公室》在Netflix上有了新的生命，到处都是。
Do you get stopped? Do you get recognized for being on the show? What it mostly is on social media is that I was on other things since then like when I was on Nashville. I played a character called Deacon and I was people would watch it and it was a very dramatic very sort of he was a he was in AA and he was he was trying not to drink anymore and he loved this woman so it was always very dramatic, very heartfelt, played music, did all these things. So inevitably I would see a tweet that would say, just realized that Deacon from Nashville
你会被拦住吗？你会被认出是节目里的演员吗？在社交媒体上，主要是因为我从那以后还参加了其他节目，比如我在《纳什维尔》的时候。我扮演了一个叫迪肯的角色，人们会看它，那是一个非常戏剧化、非常，某种程度上，他在戒酒互助会，他试图不再喝酒，他爱这个女人，所以它总是非常戏剧化、非常感人，演奏音乐，做了所有这些事情。所以不可避免地，我会看到一条推文说，刚意识到《纳什维尔》里的迪肯
is Josh from Stanford. And then it always had that hashtag, mind blown. So that's mostly where it happened. It used to be that the office was a little bit more niche, like somebody go, I know you're from the office, but now it's, you're right, there's just where it happened. It used to be that the office was a little bit more niche, like somebody go, I know you're from the office, but now it's, you're right. There's just a resurgence. There's a second thing.
是斯坦福的乔什。然后它总是带有那个标签，震惊。所以这主要是发生的地方。过去《办公室》稍微小众一点，比如有人会说，我知道你是《办公室》里的，但现在，你是对的，有复苏。有第二件事。
The best evidence of that is my own kids. When I was doing this show, they were in junior high, elementary, maybe one of them was in high school. No, they weren't, they were in junior high. So they didn't know what the office was really. They didn't watch television at all. But now, going back,
最好的证据就是我自己的孩子。当我做这个节目时，他们还在初中、小学，也许其中一个在高中。不，他们没有，他们在初中。所以他们不知道《办公室》到底是什么。他们根本不看电视。但现在，回过头来看，
how many years has it been that this resurgence, three years more? Whatever it is. Oh gosh, it feels like in the last three or four years. Yeah, the last three years, I think. It was always on in our house. I think I told Angela, it was on in the summer more than the air conditioning.
已经过去多少年了，这次复苏，又过了三年？不管是什么。哦天哪，感觉是在过去三四年里。是的，过去三年，我想。它总是在我们家里播放。我想我告诉过安吉拉，它在夏天播放的时间比空调还多。
It was just, and they fell in love with it. They knew it so well. So that was maybe the first time when it was really cool. They were cool, chill about it, like, yeah, you're on it. But I could tell it meant a lot. And it means a lot to me. Aw, that is so cool. The other rabbit hole I fall down with you guys is the,
就是那样，他们爱上了它。他们对它太熟悉了。所以那可能是第一次感觉真的很酷。他们对此表现得很酷、很放松，就像是，没错，你参与其中了。但我能看出这意义重大。对我来说也意义重大。噢，那太酷了。我和你们一起掉进的另一个兔子洞是，
what do you call it? The bloopers, the bloopers on Netflix. If I start watching one, I'm there all the time. And I think that's because it's the best of remembering the parts of the show you love so much. But then getting to see how authentically funny it struck you guys. Like sometimes you'd be watching you go, this is insane. They don't seem to think this is funny. I mean, I'm an actor and I would think that. And then you come away and you would see where everybody did break up at that line or where there would
你管它叫什么？NG片段，Netflix上的NG片段。如果我开始看一个，我就一直停不下来。我想那是因为这是记住你非常喜欢的剧集片段的最佳方式。但同时也能看到这些片段让你们觉得有多么真实地好笑。就像有时你会看着想，这太疯狂了。他们看起来并不觉得这好笑。我是说，我是一个演员，我会那么想。然后你会看到每个人在某句台词上笑场的地方，或者
be lines that you just could not get out to save your life. And those always killed me. And also the scenes that never made it. I had a great scene with Melora, um, that didn't, that didn't make it in. We were at the convention and at the end of the night, all this stuff is going on. Um, I'm walking Jan and Josh are walking, uh, towards the elevators and basically Jan stops and invites Josh on up for the night. That's on the DVD set. She totally hits on you. And you're like, nah, I'm good.
有些台词你拼了命也说不出来。那些总是让我笑死。还有那些从未播出的场景。我和Melora有一场很棒的戏，嗯，没能播出。我们在开会，那天晚上结束时，所有这些事情都在发生。嗯，我走着，Jan和Josh正朝电梯走去，基本上Jan停下来邀请Josh上去过夜。那在DVD套装里。她完全是在勾引你。而你却说，不，我很好。
Nah, I'm good. I'm good. I'm gonna go to Staples. Exactly. I know you talked about how you were the good boss, but in this episode, at the end, you sort of serve up the ultimate betrayal and you leverage your job for a position at Staples.
不，我很好。我很好。我要去Staples。没错。我知道你谈到你是如何成为好老板的，但在这一集中，最后，你算是奉上了终极背叛，并利用你的工作换取了Staples的一个职位。
What did you think when you read that? Were you disappointed at all in Josh? Or did you, were you like I get it, I mean who wants to work with this group of loonies? At that point I was just more disappointed for Chip than I was disappointed in Josh. Because I knew that Ed and Rashida were moving on over and I knew it, I always knew that it wouldn't work to have the other boss there with him. I just saw something the other day, Janet, that, look, I've done a lot of drama. There are moments, the moment where
当你读到那段时你是怎么想的？你对Josh感到失望吗？还是说，你当时想的是我理解，毕竟谁想和这群疯子一起工作？在那一点上，我更多的是为Chip感到失望，而不是对Josh感到失望。因为我知道Ed和Rashida要搬过去了，我知道，我一直知道让另一个老板和他待在那里是行不通的。我前几天刚看到一些东西，Janet，看，我演过很多剧情片。有些时刻，他非常欣赏你的画作，他说，那是我们的办公室，而你只是看着他，然后你拥抱了他。对我来说，那和任何地方的任何剧情片一样感人、真实且令人心碎。所以这也是我一直喜欢它和你们的原因。噢，是的，当然。我是说，Steve在这部剧里多次让我心碎。和任何地方的任何剧情片一样令人心碎。所以这也是我一直喜欢它和你们的原因。
he admires your painting so much, and he says, that's our office, and you're just looking at him, and you hug him. That's, to me, as emotional and as real and as heartbreaking as any drama anywhere. So that's another thing I've always loved about it, and you guys. Oh yeah, for sure. I mean, Steve broke my heart many times on this show. Heartbreaking is any drama anywhere. So that's another thing I've always loved about it and you guys.
噢，是的，当然。我是说，Steve在这部剧里多次让我心碎，仅仅是因为他作为Michael那种孩子般的纯真，尽管他很多时候真的就像，我不知道，就像个白痴。但他也是一个内心非常纯洁且复杂的人。是的，我现在回头看，我知道这对编剧来说有多难。我们看过
Oh yeah, for sure. I mean, Steve broke my heart many times on the show, just with his sort of childlike innocence as Michael, even though he was a lot of times just a real like, I don't know, like idiot. Like he was also this very pure hearted person and complicated. Yeah, and I look now and I know how hard that is for writers. We've seen out things on
不同剧集又拍了一季又一季，就像他们是怎么把这一切维持在一起的，因为那总是张力所在。当你有了傻瓜，当你有了更正经的人，让他们变得有趣的是他们有多么出格。让他们变得人性化的是这种基础，并展现出另一面。这两者之间的张力，很难把握，你不能让他们变得不再有趣，因为现在他们只是超人般善良。难道我们不爱他们吗？或者有时你只是让他们看起来根本没有任何弧光。
different shows that go another season and another season it's like how do they keep it all together because that's always the tension. When you have the fool, when you have the more honor people, what makes them funny is how out there they are. What makes them human is the grounding of that and giving up the other side. That tension between those two things, it is so hard to ride where you don't make them not funny anymore because now they're just superhuman and kind. And don't we love them? Or other times you just leave them like they don't have any arc at all.
他们只是同一个人。他们一直都是那样，他们多年来对你们所做的方式非常不寻常且特别。嗯，你的角色Josh有一个很棒的弧光。确实。你以为我是个完美的人。那是另一件事，我一直认为这很有魅力。
They're just that same person. They always were the way that they did that over the seasons with you guys is just it's very unusual and special. Well, your character of Josh had a great arc. I did. You thought I was the perfect guy. That is the other thing is that I always thought this is charismatic.
对他来说一切都很容易。最后，他做了那个。我还有一件有趣的事。当Ed在我最后一集时，Josh是分部基本上要关闭的原因。所以在那一点上，他认为自己不再有工作了。他只是在抓狂，Andy是这样。
It all comes very easy to him. And in the end, he does that. I had one other fun thing. When Ed was on my final episode, Josh is the reason that branch is essentially gonna be shutting down. So at that point, he doesn't think he has a job anymore. He's just flipping out, Andy is.
所以他们在厨房里有一场戏，所有的戏就是，Andy走进去，他在倒咖啡什么的，突然我们得到了Andy Bernard那种愤怒的第一个暗示，他后来不得不处理。他只是抓狂，把一切都毁了，然后停下来。那就是那场戏。
So there's a scene in the kitchen they had and all the scene was, was Andy walks in there, he's pouring some coffee or something and all of a sudden we get that first hint of that Andy Bernard anger that he later has to deal with. And he just flips out and sort of destroys everything and stops. And that was the scene.
我很自豪，因为我说，如果Josh，那个导致这一切的人，在那之后走进来会怎样？只是为了说再见，我猜Andy不够坚强或勇敢，除了说，太棒了。这太棒了。然后只是，你知道，
And I was real proud because I said, what if Josh, the guy that's the cause of all it, walked in right after that? And just to say goodbye, my guess is that Andy is not strong enough or brave enough to do anything but go, great. It was awesome. And just, you know,
他必须立即掩盖他的愤怒，在那一刻表现得最糟糕。他们说，好，试试看。所以那很有趣。他毁了那个房间，我走进去说，听着，Andy，这太棒了。他就像，是的，太棒了，Andy。
he would have to cover his fury immediately and be sort of the worst that he was in that moment. And they said, yeah, let's try that. So that was a lot of fun. He destroys that room and I walk in there and I go, listen, Andy, it's been great. And he's like, yeah, awesome, Andy.
祝你好运之类的。所以那也很酷。噢天哪，我喜欢。那是你的提议。我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。你知道，Chip，我们经常谈论这个，我们有这种创造性的合作，
Good luck and everything like that. So that was very cool too. Oh my gosh, I love it. That was your pitch. I love that. I love that. You know, Chip, we talk about this a lot, that we had this creative collaboration,
我们可以在那一刻向片场的编剧提出建议，而且我们被听取了。这真的很罕见，真的。我们很幸运能与我们的编剧建立那种关系。我喜欢那个。我们不知道。我们不知道那是你的提议。
that we could in the moment pitch something to the writer on set, and we were heard. And that is so rare, truly. And we were so lucky to have that relationship with our writers. And I love that. We didn't know that. We didn't know that was your pitch.
那太酷了。而且也推进了Andy这个角色，因为Andy总是紧紧压抑着他的愤怒，你知道，直到最后，你知道，他要打墙。但你喜欢看他试图控制那种情绪，这也很Andy。所以能看到这一点很酷。我们也能看到。还有另一件事，当你有一个小想法，一个小提议时，有多酷，
That's so cool. And also furthers the Andy character, because Andy was always just white knuckling his anger, you know, and suppressing it until eventually, you know, he's going to punch the wall. But you love seeing him try to contain that such an Andy thing, too. So that's kind of cool that I get to see that. And we get to see. And also the other thing, how cool is it when you have a little idea, a little pitch, and
你被那些会让你的提议变得惊人的人包围着。我在其他地方提出过建议，他们尝试了，但并没有像你在脑海中那样实现。但那个被采纳了，甚至超出了我能想象的程度，他用它做了什么。它完全做到了，而且绝对结晶了Andy是谁，你知道，那一刻的所有一切都说明了他是什么样的人。那太棒了。我喜欢那个故事。噢，Chip，非常感谢。
you're surrounded by people that are going to make your pitch amazing. I've been in other places where you make a pitch and they try it and it just doesn't get sold the way that you had it in your head. But that got sold out and beyond anything I could imagine what he did with it. It totally did and it absolutely just crystallized who Andy was, you know, just all of that moment says who he is. That is fantastic. I love that story. Aw, Chip, thank you so much.
感谢你来到这里分享你在办公室的时光。我们很高兴能联系到你。谢谢你们。我们在哪里可以找到你？告诉我们你在Instagram上的位置。我是Charles下划线Esten。我在Twitter和Facebook上也是Charles Esten。还有Chip你也是
Thank you for coming on here and sharing about your time on the office. We are so glad that we got ahold of you. Thank you guys. Where can we find you? Tell us where you are on Instagram. I'm at Charles underscore Esten. I'm also Charles Esten on Twitter and Facebook. And Chip you're also
你在Netflix上有一个叫Outer Banks的节目。是的，我们在Netflix上排名第一。哇。包括一个叫办公室的小节目。有一会儿是这样。这真是太神奇了，我们去年夏天拍的。这是一种年轻人的惊险冒险。有它自己惊人的生命力。正如我所说，我们把Tiger King挤下了第一名。Tiger King，那可不简单。那说明了一些问题。
on you're on a show right now called Outer Banks on Netflix. Yeah we were number one on Netflix. Wow. Including a little show called The Office. For a quick minute there yeah. It's something else it's really kind of amazing we shot it last summer. It's sort of a young adult, thrilling adventure. Has this amazing life of its own. As I said, we knocked Tiger King out of first place. Tiger King, that's something. That says something.
然后我还有一件事要和大家分享。你每周六做Facebook直播，叫Quarantine Livestream。是这样吗？是的，因为Nashville这个节目，我必须在上面演奏很多音乐。所以这就是为什么我还在Nashville。我可以做非常酷的事情。
And then I have one more thing to share with everyone. You do a weekly Saturday Facebook live stream and it's called Quarantine Livestream. Is that right? Yeah, because of the show Nashville, I had to play a lot of music on that. So that's why Iarantine Livestream. Is that right? Yeah, because of the show Nashville, I have to play a lot of music on that. So that's why I'm still here in Nashville. I get to do very cool things.
我在Grand Ole Opry或Bluebird或Ryman演奏。噢，哇。然后巡回演出并制作音乐。所以我也在Spotify上。但无论如何，所以我只是在节目上，在Quarantine Livestream上演奏几首歌。然后我做另一件事，我和某人合唱。我发给他们我唱歌的视频。
I play at the Grand Ole Opry or the Bluebird or the Ryman. Oh, wow. And tour around and make music. So I'm on Spotify too. But in any event, so I just play a couple songs on the show, on the Quarantine Livestream. And then I do another thing where I do a duet with somebody. I send them video of me singing.
他们听着并跟着唱，我们把它们放在一个视频里。所以总有一个二重唱。然后我也做采访。就像你们现在做的一样。噢，这是上周的。是的，上周是Old Dominion。我采访了Old Dominion乐队。
They listen and sing along and we put them together in a video. So there's always a duet. And then I do interviews as well. Just like you're doing right here. Oh, this was last week. Yeah, last week was Old Dominion. The band Old Dominion I interviewed.
好吧，Chip，非常感谢。这真是一种享受。噢，非常感谢你们邀请我。我喜欢你们在做这个。我喜欢你们在做这个。每个人都喜欢你们在做这个。这个东西火了，这个播客，因为他们除了和你们讨论这些事情还能想要什么呢？所以做得好。
Well, Chip, thank you so much. This was such a delight. Oh, thank you guys very much for having me. I love that you're doing this. I love that you're doing this. Everybody loves that you're doing this. This thing is on fire, this podcast, because what would they want more than discuss these things with you guys? So well done.
希望以后能在其他情况下见到你们。但谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢，Chip。我们爱你。爱你。我也爱你。再见，伙计们。再见。
And hopefully I get to see you down the road in some other situation. But thanks for having me. Thanks, Chip. We love you. Love you. Love you too. Bye guys. Bye.
好了。所以那太棒了。非常感谢，Chip。那。好了。所以那太棒了。非常感谢，Chip。那真的很酷。我很高兴我们能纪念他在剧中的时光。对于所有其他Chip斜杠Charles们，Jenna滑进了你们的私信，我们道歉。没错。
All right. So that was amazing. Thank you so much, Chip. That. All right. So that was amazing. Thank you so much, Chip. That was really cool. I'm glad we were able to commemorate his time on the show. And to all of you other Chips slash Charles's out there that Jenna slid into your DMs, we apologize. That's right.
好的，Jenna，我们在哪里？所以Dwight和Michael还在David Wallace的房子外面，他们决定要练习。他们要角色扮演Michael在看到David走过来时要说什么，对吧？是的，他们必须做好准备。是的。所以我和Mike Schur交换了一些信息，
Okay, Jenna, where are we? So Dwight and Michael are still outside of David Wallace's house, and they've decided that they're going to practice. They're going to role play what Michael is going to say when he sees David walking up, right? Yeah, they've got to be prepared. Yes. So I traded some messages with Mike Schur,
他告诉我，场景中有一个元素是即兴创作的，它让每个人都笑得太厉害了，以至于他们能够保留它，但他们必须在那一刻剪掉，因为在那一刻之后，就像那一刻之后一秒，每个人都开始笑场了。所以在这一幕中，当他们角色扮演时，
and he told me that there was an element of the scene that was improvised, and it made everyone laugh so hard that they were able to keep it in, but they had to cut at this one moment because right after that moment, like one second after that moment, everyone started breaking. So during this scene, when they're role playing,
Dwight假装是David Wallace，他做得很好。他提出了很好的论点。所以Michael感到沮丧，他有这句台词，他说类似的话，回去重新开始，对我更敬畏一点。好的，那本该是结束的地方。
Dwight is pretending to be David Wallace and he's doing a good job. He's making good arguments. So Michael gets frustrated and he has this line where he says something like, just go back and start over and be more intimidated by me. Okay, that's where it was supposed to end.
那是剧本中场景的结尾。但当他们拍摄时，Rain走回来，Steve说，Wallace先生？Rain说，啊！就像他被吓坏了一样。那是Mike说太棒了的那一刻。我们真的不能再往后剪一帧了，因为他们两个都开始歇斯底里地大笑。
That was the scripted ending of the scene. But when they shot it, Rain walks back in, and Steve says, Mr. Wallace? Rain goes, ah! Kind of like he's terrified. That was the moment Mike said it was amazing. And we literally couldn't go one frame later because they both started laughing hysterically.
是的，我喜欢那个。因为Steve作为Michael就像是，对我更害怕一点，别碰我。是的，太好了。太好了。好了，现在，Lady，你想让我告诉你关于这只狗的事吗？是的，我想让我告诉你关于这只狗的事吗？
Yes, I love that. Because Steve as Michael is like, be more scared of me and don't touch me. Yeah. It was so good. It was so good. All right, so now, Lady, do you want me to tell you about this dog? Yes, I want me to tell you about this dog?
是的。我想让你告诉我关于这只狗的事，因为我看到了门垫，我就想，噢是的，他们只是忘了。他们忘了。然后我看到了狗，我就想，好吧，那是那些人的狗，对吧？不。这太疯狂了。好了。所以有Dwight在垃圾里翻找的场景。顺便说一句，他翻找垃圾的这一幕，这是另一场被剪掉的场景
Yes. I want you to tell me about the dog because I saw the doormat and I was like, oh yeah, they just forgot. They forgot. And then I saw the dog and I was like, well then that's those people's dog, right? No. It's crazy. All right. So there's the scene where Dwight is sifting through the garbage. And by the way, this scene of him looking through the garbage, this was another one of those scenes that had been cut
对于这一集的常规网络播出。我们收到了很多关于这一幕的问题。Jocelyn Beecher写信说，在David Wallace家19分钟时，院子里有一只狗。他们是专门为狗选角的，还是那只狗属于房主？好了，后院里的那只狗
for the regular network airing of this episode. We got a ton of questions about this scene. Jocelyn Beecher wrote in and said, at 19 minutes at David Wallace's house, there's a dog in the yard. Did they specifically cast for a dog, or did that dog belong to the people who own the house? All right, the dog in the backyard
是他们添加的东西。他们添加它是为了认为如果Dwight在翻找垃圾时，有这只看门狗或护卫犬站在他身后，可能会有更多的危险感。那是有史以来看起来最友好的狗。那只狗在摇尾巴。它看起来就像只是想玩捡球游戏。
was something that they added. And they added it because they thought that there might be more of a feeling of jeopardy involved if there was like this guard dog or this watchdog standing behind Dwight as he sifted through the garbage. That was the friendliest looking dog ever. That dog was wagging its tail. It looked like it just wanted to play fetch.
那只狗让我想再养一只狗，我们已经有两只狗和两只猫了。我是说……我知道。Kent告诉我他们雇了一位训狗师。他们雇了这只狗，它太甜了。它只是想玩。它只是想，就像，只是想舔你的手。
That dog made me want to get another dog, and we already have two dogs and two cats. I mean... I know. Kent told me they hired a dog trainer. They hired this dog, and he was so sweet. He just wanted to play. He just wanted to, like, just wanted to like lick your hand.
看起来就是那样。一点也不吓人，就像你说的。是的。但他们坚持下去了。他们坚持下去了。他们就像，这只狗要出现在镜头里。我们为这只狗付了钱。好吧，这只狗看起来太友好了。
That's what it looks like. In no way intimidating, just like you said. Yeah. But they stuck with it. They stuck with it. They're like, this dog is going to be in the shot. We paid for this dog. Well, the dog looks so friendly.
对我来说，我只是以为主人的狗在镜头后面跑出来了，他们就把它留在了里面。看起来就是那样。完全是。好了，听着，回到Scranton，Phyllis很沮丧。她正试图组织一次集体午餐。是的。
To me, I just thought the owner's dog got out in the back of the shot and they left it in. That's what it looked like. Totally. All right, well, listen, back in Scranton, Phyllis is bummed out. She's trying to organize a group lunch. Yeah.
是的，当然，她去找了扫兴的人，Angela Martin。他们正在抛出一些东西。DJs，顺便说一句，DJs是一家三明治店。然后是Cogino's Italian family cuisine，对吧？Angela说，我不想开车去Dunmore。Jenna，我查了一下，Scranton到Dunmore，九分钟。噢，你不想开车九分钟。九分钟。
Yeah, and of course, she goes to the fun stopper, Angela Martin. And they're throwing out some things. DJs, which by the way, DJs is a hoagie shop. And then there's Cogino's Italian family cuisine, right? And Angela's like, I don't want to drive to Dunmore. Jenna, I looked it up, Scranton to Dunmore, nine minutes. Oh, you don't want to drive nine minutes. Nine minutes.
然后Kevin说，Cooper's怎么样？她说，不，海鲜。我想让你知道Brian和我在去Scranton时去过Cooper's，他们给了我们像龙虾一样的小帽子。你管它们叫什么？钳子？是的，他们每人给了我们一顶帽子。我有Brian和我戴着这些龙虾钳帽子喝啤酒的照片。这真的很有趣。但是的，Angela Martin非常反对海鲜。然后我甚至不敢相信Kevin向她建议Hooters。你在开玩笑吗？
And then Kevin's like, what about Cooper's? And she's like, no, seafood. And I want you to know Brian and I have been to Coopers when we went to Scranton and they gave us like a little hat that looks like lobster. What do you call them? Claws? Yeah, they gave us each hat. I have photos of Brian and I like drinking beers with these lobster claw hats on. It was really fun. But yeah, Angela Martin's very against seafood. And then I can't even believe Kevin suggests Hooters to her. Are you kidding me?
我知道。在这中间，Phyllis只是走开了。她说，算了。是的，你们是最糟糕的。忘了它吧。是的。与此同时，Creed正在四处走动。他正在通过卖掉一切来处理这件事
I know. In the middle of all this, Phyllis just walks away. She's like, never mind. Yeah, you guys are the worst. Forget it. Yeah. At the same time, Creed is walking around. He's dealing with this by selling everything
在办公室里。他正在卖设备、传真机、他的个人电脑。我想如果你看他身后的墙，墙上的除尘器。KATE BOWEN 它不见了。我有一个Creed的头发捕捉。我想这一集Creed有一个新发型。
in the office. He's selling the equipment, the fax machine, his personal computer. And I think if you look on the wall behind him, the dust buster off the wall. KATE BOWEN It's gone. I have a hair catch for Creed. I think this episode debuts a new hairstyle for Creed.
它是蓬松的。就像他们用吹风机把它直吹到空中，然后用滚刷。我想让你看看他的头发。它太蓬松了。它让我笑了。Lady，我注意到了同样的事情。我有同样的笔记。
It's poofy. It's like they blow-dried it straight up in the air and then used a rolling brush. I want you to look at his hair. It is so poofy. It made me laugh. Lady, I noticed the same thing. I had the same note.
Creed的头发？是的。我写下，Creed的头发怎么了？他们对他用了滚刷吗？就像，发生了什么？我们必须追踪它，因为我想看看这种做Creed头发的新方式是否会在以后的剧集中继续。
Creed hair? Yeah. I wrote down, what's up with Creed's hair? Did they use the rolling brush on him? Like, what's happening? We're going to have to track it because I want to see if that continues in future episodes, this new way of doing Creed's hair.
蓬松的。它太蓬松了。是的。顺便说一句，Creed卖东西的整个故事情节，那是最初被剪掉并为加长版添加回来的另一件事。所以三件主要的事情是Meredith的故事情节、这个Creed的故事情节和Dwight翻垃圾。明白了。带着那只友好的狗。是的，带着那只友好的狗。
The poofy. It's so poofy. Yes. By the way, that whole storyline of Creed selling stuff, that was the other thing that was cut out originally and was added back for the extended cut. So the three main things were the Meredith storyline, this Creed storyline, and Dwight going through the trash. Got it. With the friendly dog. Yes, with the friendly dog.
好了。所以现在Jan进来了。她在找Michael，因为事情变了。Josh Porter让他们陷入了困境。他们不得不重组，她想让他知道现在Scranton留下来了，Stanford要合并到Scranton，对吧？是的。但Michael一直不接电话。
All right. So now Jan enters. She's looking for Michael because things have changed. Josh Porter threw them for a loop. They've had to reorganize restructure, and she wants to let him know that now Scranton is staying and Stanford is going to be merging into Scranton, right? Yes. But Michael has been ignoring phone calls.
而且Lady，我们有一些主要的Phyllis傲慢。什么是Phyllis傲慢？嗯，是在20分钟40秒。她看着Jan说，我们知道分部要关闭了。她给了Jan最讽刺的眼神。这太棒了。它让我笑了起来，我在网上搜索像傲慢的办公室时刻。
And lady, we have some major phyllis sass. What's the phyllis sass? Well, it is at 20 minutes, 40 seconds. She looks at Jan and she goes, we know the branch is closing. And she gives Jan the snarkiest look. It's so amazing. It cracked me up and I was looking online for like sassy office moments.
我只是想看看这是否被记录下来了。Jenna，在2020年5月16日，也就是距离这次录音只有几天，对吧？是的。YouTube上有一个新的YouTube视频拼贴，有人制作了叫YouTube上最傲慢的时刻。办公室里最傲慢的时刻。我想他们一直在听播客
I just wanted to see if this had been clocked. Jenna, on May 16th, 2020, which is just a few days ago from this recording, right? Yes. There is a new YouTube video collage that someone made called Sassiest Moments on YouTube. Sassiest Moments from the office. I think they have been listening to the podcast
因为突然之间YouTube上有了最傲慢时刻的拼贴。Angela，你100%开始了傲慢。你很早就开始了Angela傲慢。如果外面有人在使用傲慢或傲慢地说话，或者把某事称为傲慢，我想让每个人都知道是你开始的。100%你交易，你应该注册商标吗？嗯，我只是不敢相信现在，就在现在，就像这周，有一个叫办公室最傲慢时刻的YouTube拼贴。无论如何，这里有主要的Phyllis傲慢。
because all of a sudden there's the Sassiestiest moments collage on YouTube. Angela, you 100% started SaaS. You started it early with Angela SaaS. And if anyone is out there using SaaS or sassing or referring to something as SaaS, I want everyone to know that you started it. 100% you trade, you should have trademarked it? Well, I just couldn't believe there's now, just now, like just this week, there's a YouTube collage called Sassiest Moments of the Office. Anyway, there's major Phyllis Sass here.
所以是的，Jan告诉每个人Scranton分部目前是安全的。有很多复杂的情绪。有些人真的很高兴。有些人很伤心。Kevin和Angela有一个巨大的拥抱。噢，Lady，我们收到了Phoebe Tomack关于那个的粉丝问题。当Kevin拥抱Angela并抱起她时，看起来Angela被压碎了一点，她想知道你是否受伤了。
So yes, Jan tells everyone the Scranton branch is safe for now. There's a lot of mixed emotions. Some people are really happy. Some people are sad. Kevin and Angela have a huge hug. Oh, lady, we got a fan question about that from Phoebe Tomack. When Kevin hugs Angela and picks her up, it looks like Angela got crushed a little bit, and she wants to know if you got hurt.
不，我没有受伤。那只是，我想，Brian玩得有点开心，因为他是一个大块头，他可以很容易地抱起我。我们的角色什么时候会拥抱或在一起这么开心？所以那只是他添加的东西。剧本里没有。他和我都笑了起来。
No, I did not get hurt. That was just, I think, Brian having a little bit of fun because he is such a big guy, and he can pick me up really easily. And when would our characters ever hug or be this happy together? So that was just something he added. It wasn't in the script. And he and I cracked up.
我想你看到我像，我想我是真心地在笑，因为它让我们笑了。所以也在这一幕中，Angela，Pam问Jan，有人要回Scranton吗？我们知道她在想谁。是的。而在Stanford，Andy问Jim他是否要回Scranton。他算是说他还不知道。
I think you see me like, I think I'm genuinely laughing because it made us laugh. So also in the scene, Angela, Pam asks Jan, is anyone coming back to Scranton? We know who she's thinking about. Yeah. And over in Stanford, Andy is asking Jim if he's going to go back to Scranton. And he sort of says he doesn't know yet.
他不确定。他在考虑。然后厨房里的Ryan就像，我有点紧张Jim回来。我只是希望这不会很奇怪。Pam，当然，完全内化了这一点。就像，噢天哪，他知道。他知道。他说，我抢了他的工作。
He's not sure. He's thinking about it. And then Ryan in the kitchen is like, I'm a little nervous about Jim coming back. I just hope it's not weird. Pam, of course, totally internalizes this. Like, oh my god, he knows. He knows. And he's like, I took his job.
我坐在他的桌子上。这更多的是关于，这都是关于他，对吧？是的。所以Pam在那一刻感到有点宽慰。接下来，Ryan要进行他的采访，他知道他会留在Scranton，这是那一刻，从现在开始23分钟6秒，所有的采访都面向办公室内部。
I sit at his desk. It's more about, it's all about him, right? Yeah. And so Pam is kind of relieved in that moment. Next, Ryan's going to have his talking head, where he knows he'll be saying at Scranton, here's the moment, 23 minutes, six seconds from here on out, all of the talking heads are facing back into the office.
噢，Lady。这是你最自豪的播客深度挖掘时刻，也许。我想是这样。我认为这和你关于阿尔法子宫的深度挖掘并列。噢，我很享受阿尔法子宫。是的，你享受了。是的，你享受了。然后回到Stanford，Karen说，你知道，如果他们提供的话，她会搬到Scranton。Jim给了这个可怜的女人这么多混合信息。好的，和Jim有一些矛盾，因为他就像，你为什么要那样做？去纽约吧。我是说，你离纽约45分钟。你为什么要
Oh, lady. This is your proudest podcast deep dive moment, maybe. I think it is. I think this ranks right up there with your alpha womb deep dive. Oh, I did enjoy alpha womb. Yes, you did. Yes, you did. Then over in Stanford, Karen is saying, you know, she would move to Scranton if they offered it to her. Jim gives this poor woman so many mixed messages. Okay, some beef with Jim, because he's like, why would you do that? Just go to New York. I mean, you're 45 minutes from New York. Why would
去Scranton？对吧？然后他在最后又转回另一个方向，告诉她接受这份工作。我感到难过。我为她感到难过。我觉得这些混合信息会在整个Jim和Karen的关系中发挥作用，实际上。是的。在我看来，Jim对她非常摇摆不定。在23分钟17秒的这一幕中，我有一个Lee捕捉。你的丈夫Lee？我的丈夫Lee。你就像Angela，你就像我在谈论什么其他的Lee？
you go to Scranton? Right? And then he pivots back the other way at the end and tells her to take the job. I feel bad. I feel bad for her. I feel like these mixed messages are going to play out through the whole Jim Caron relationship, actually. Yeah. Jim is very wishy washy with her, in my opinion. In this scene at 23 minutes, 17 seconds, I have a Lee catch. Your husband Lee? My husband Lee. You're like Angela, you're like what other Lee am I talking about?
就像是的，我的丈夫Lee。好的，我的丈夫Lee。我们一起看了这一集，他说，噢天哪，看Karen头后面的标志，在关于她是否应该搬到Scranton的谈话中。你知道它写着什么吗？不。它写着，机会之窗。一个人的障碍是另一个人的机会。
Like yes, my husband Lee. Okay, my husband Lee. We watched this episode together and he said, oh my gosh, look at the sign behind Karen's head during this conversation about whether or not she should move to Scranton. Do you know what it says? No. It says, window of opportunity. An obstacle to one is an opportunity to another.
噢。我只是认为我们认为这很有趣，因为我正在向他展示所有的采访，他就像，噢，看Karen后面是什么。这是一个机会之窗。层层叠叠。好吧，回到Scranton，Meredith正在祝贺Creed的商业冒险。他赚了1200美元。最后，Gary Trendle打电话来了。
Oh. I just thought we thought this was interesting because I was showing him all the talking heads and he was like, oh, look at what's behind Karen. It's a window of opportunity. Layers, layers. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith is congratulating Creed on his business venture. He's made $1,200. And finally, Gary Trendle calls.
他给Meredith打电话。你知道为什么吗？他曾经在Scranton分部工作，他说，我听说分部要关闭了。你还想履行我们的协议吗？Meredith找到了她的人。她确实和某人达成了性协议。她差点承认分部没有关闭，然后她就像，你能在20分钟后在我的地方见我吗？我们收到了Bailey Aspenson在24分钟30秒的粉丝问题，当Meredith
He calls Meredith. Do you know why? He used to work at the Scranton branch and he says, I heard the branch was closing. Do you still want to make good on our agreement? Meredith found her guy. She did make a sex pact with someone. She almost confesses the branch isn't closing and then she's like, can you meet me at my place in 20 minutes? We had a fan question from Bailey Aspenson at 24 minutes 30 seconds when Meredith
在电话里说话时。她在和谁说话？你知道吗？我当然不知道。Kent Subornak。终于Kent。Kentopedia。终于Kent。Kent Subornak扮演了Gary Trundle的声音。他本来会是我的第一个嘉宾，是的。所以Dwight和Michael在车里，他们现在在回忆关于Dunder Mifflin的最爱记忆，因为他们忽略了电话，你知道，他们不知道他们的工作是安全的。Dwight对Michael说，你最喜欢的记忆是什么？
is talking on the phone. Who is she talking to? Do you know? Of course I don't know. Kent Subornak. Finally Kent. Kentopedia. Finally Kent. Kent Subornak played the voice of Gary Trundle. He was going gonna be my first guest, yes. So Dwight and Michael are in the car and they're reminiscing now about their favorite memories of Dunder Mifflin because they've ignored phone calls, you know, and they don't know that their jobs are safe. And Dwight says to Michael, what's your favorite memory?
你知道，他说，这一切，这一切。然后Dwight说，甚至分部关闭的那部分。他说，Dwight，当Rain说那句台词时，那是剧本写的吗？是的，车里的那一幕几乎是逐字逐句写的。好的，我不知道那是否像Rain在场景结尾加的。
You know, and he goes, all of it, all of it. And then Dwight goes, even the part where the branch was closed. And he's like, Dwight, was that part scripted when Rain said it was? Yes, that scene in the car is almost word for word scripted. All right, I didn't know if that was like Rain tagging the end of the scene.
所以我喜欢那个。这太有趣了，Angela，因为我知道那个的原因是因为我在看它时也有同样的想法，我检查了。我想知道，那是剧本写的吗？好吧，事情是这样的。我们经常可以在场景结尾加一句台词。那是即兴创作最容易的地方
So I love that. It's so funny, Angela, because the reason I know that is because I had the same thought when I watched it and I checked. I wanted to know, is that scripted? Well, here's the thing. We often could add a line at the end of a scene. That's the easiest place to improvise
因为它并没有真正搞乱场景的背景。所以每当我看到这些结尾的小抛弃，特别是Steve和Rain的，我总是很好奇。是的。不。那个是完全、完全写在剧本里的。好吧，现在我们回到Scranton，大家要出去喝一杯。Creed请客，因为Creed今天赚了一些钱。Jenna，你注意到Angela离开时给Roy挥手有多大吗？
because it doesn't really mess up the context of the scene. So whenever I see these little throwaways at the end, especially by Steve and Rain, I always wonder. Yeah. Nope. That one was totally, totally scripted. Well, now we're back at Scranton, and the gang is going out for shots. Creed is buying because Creed made some money today. Jenna, did you notice as Angela leaves what a big wave she gives to Roy?
不，这是更多、更多关于Angela和Roy的。噢天哪，这几乎很尴尬。这几乎很尴尬。在26分钟35秒，她走过去，字面上是这样做的。你们看不到我，但我会为Jenna做。噢，那是一个大挥手。是的，这是一个非常大的挥手。
No, this is more, more of Angela and Roy. Oh my gosh, it's almost awkward. It's almost awkward. At 26 minutes, 35 seconds, she walks by and literally goes like this. You guys can't see me, but I'm gonna do it for Jenna. Oh, that's a big wave. Yes, it's a really big wave.
所以她肯定就像，再见，帅哥。好吧，Pam现在有她的采访面向办公室内部，我会说。而且她很轻浮。她很轻浮。她说类似的话，噢，你知道，这很好，因为找另一份工作有点麻烦，而且，而且有留下的理由。但在内心深处，她所想的只是，Jim要回来了，Jim要回来了，Jim要回来了，Jim要回来了。那是一切，一切。你为她感到如此兴奋。然后我们去Stanford，Jim告诉Karen他认为她也应该在Scranton找份工作。
So she for sure is like, bye, handsome. Well, Pam now has her talking head facing into the office, I will say. And she is giddy. She's giddy. She's saying stuff like, oh, you know, it's good because finding another job is kind of a pain and, and there are reasons to stay. But underneath, all she is thinking is, Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back. That's everything, everything. And you're so excited for her. And then we go to Stanford, and Jim tells Karen he thinks she should take a job in Scranton too.
Karen只是把一切都摆在摄像机组面前。她就像，嘿，我很高兴你这么说。我不认为他喜欢我，但我有点喜欢他。所以就是这样。哇。这就像是一个对这个家伙毫无歉意地喜欢的人。我喜欢她这一点。
And Karen just lays it all out for the camera crew. She's just like, hey, I'm happy you said that. I don't think he's into me, but I'm kinda into him. So there's that. Wow. This is like someone who's sort of unapologetically into this guy. I dig it about her.
我喜欢它。Jim甚至显然没有告诉她关于Pam发生的事情。所以她正走进Scranton，她根本不知道他吻了接待员。她根本不知道有这四年的调情。她只是，我喜欢这个家伙。我要去Scranton看看会发生什么。
I like it. Jim doesn't even tell her, apparently, about what went on with Pam. So she's walking into Scranton, and she has no idea that he kissed the receptionist. She has no idea that there was this four-year flirtation. She's just like, I like this guy. I'm going to go to Scranton and see what happens.
我要再进一步说，她根本不知道他说过，我爱你。你好。我爱你。对接待员。我们现在非常支持Karen Filippelli团队。我们是，因为Jim，Jim正在螺旋式下降，让我们诚实点。我是说，听着，我可以为Jim的选择和他的行为辩护。他有一颗破碎的心，他很困惑，他很崩溃。
I'm going to take it one step more and say, she has no idea that he said, I love you. Hello. I love you. To the receptionist. We are being very Team Karen Filippelli right now. We are because Jim, Jim is spiraling, let's be honest. I mean, listen, I can justify Jim's choices and his behavior. He has a broken heart, he's confused, he's crushed.
我们都曾摇摆不定。我们都，你知道，我们都在生活中做过这些版本，并让别人对我们做过这些版本。好了，所以继续，Dwight和Michael还在David Wallace的房子外面。他从来没有回家。天黑了。他们饿了，但Dwight不让他们离开。
We've all been wishy washy. We've all, you know, we've all kind of done versions of this in our life and had versions of it done to us. All right, so moving on, Dwight and Michael are still outside David Wallace's house. He's never come home. It's dark. They're hungry, but Dwight won't let them leave.
但最后他说，是的，我们可以走了。当他们离开时，Dwight检查他的手机，显然收到了他们的工作是安全的消息。这太令人高兴了。他们就像，我们做到了！我们做到了！他们就像，等等，我们做了什么……他们开始像撞胸。是的，但他们字面上就像，我们做到了。就像，他们做了什么？甚至在最后，我想Steve作为Michael就像，等等，我们做了什么？就像……
But finally he says, yes, we can go. And as they're leaving, Dwight checks his phone, clearly gets a message that their jobs are safe. And this is delightful. They're like, we did it! We did it! They're like, wait, what did we... They start like bumping chests. Yeah, but they literally are like, we did it. Like, what did they do? And even at the end, I think Steve is Michael is like, wait, what did we do? Like...
是的，这是怎么发生的？我很困惑。然后整个……但我喜欢它。我也喜欢它。他们太高兴了。然后整集以Toby说结束，好吧，我想我不会去哥斯达黎加了。我只是，当我65岁时它会在那里。是的，完全正确。完全正确。噢，伙计们，你们有了。那是分部关闭。那是分部关闭。那是分部关闭。伙计们，下周我们有一个非常特别的剧集
Yeah, how did this happen? I'm so confused. And then the whole... But I love it. I love it too. They're so happy. And then the whole episode ends with Toby saying, well, I guess I won't go to Costa Rica. I'll just, it'll be there when I'm 65. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Oh, guys, there you have it. That's branch closing. That is branch closing. That is branch closing. Guys, next week we have a very special episode
关于Office Ladies。我们将重温我们的赌场之夜剧集，特别嘉宾，Ken Quapis。是的，导演要来给我们所有的幕后花絮。这是一集如此大的剧集，你们很多人写信进来，我们想让我们和导演一起重温它，回答你们的一些问题，并多谈谈它。非常感谢Chip打来电话，也谢谢你们收听。我们下周见。
of Office Ladies. We are going to revisit our casino night episode with special guest, Ken Quapis. Yes, the director is coming on to give us all of the behind the scenes stuff. This was such a big episode and so many of you wrote in that we thought let's revisit it with the director, answer some of your questions, and talk a little bit more about it. Thank you so much for calling in Chip and thank you guys for tuning in. We'll see you next week.
感谢收听Office Ladies的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。Office Ladies是Odyssey的呈现，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jerkins，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是Daniella Silva。Odyssey的执行制片人是Jenna Weiss-Berman和Leah Reese-Dennis。Office Ladies由Chris Basil混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的Rubber Tree。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师兼助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演唱的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。